folks. I had to take care
of few things off stream this
morning. Um, but I've been thinking
about V trace and what we can do with V
trace. So, I don't think it's completely
broken. First of
all,
because this
actually trains
somewhat like
reasonably nowhere near as good as
PO stalls at 50 instead of
Um, but you know, there's there's
definitely something there. So, I think
the main question is around the uh the
clipping stuff with PO,
right? My stream not shows
online. Okay, there we go.
So, I think the main main thing I want
to get done initially today is to figure
out what's up with B
trace
because if this works, this should fix a
lot of problems uh with all policy
correction. This should fix a lot of
stuff.
So the issue that I have right is it's
not just like a clean
replacement for
JE because you take this advantage from
J right you
norm this is just prioritized replay you
can ignore that
uh and then you do this clipped
loss
whereas VR also modifies the loss to
just be this scaled
log softmax thing,
That doesn't make much sense, does
it? Let me just put this before
prioritization. Make sure that's not the
thing messing us
values. This shouldn't work, right? If I
just do this. I think this doesn't work.
learning. But there's definitely a scale
issue
here. The scale is like way way
Hang
on. You norm the advantage. You multiply
by
pryo and then you do a flipped loss.
This loss isn't going to be scaled to
one,
right? And then a
loss that's not going to be scaled to
one.
I also I think I tried this already, but
why do you have to change the
loss with
um Why do you have to change the loss?
Why can't I just do
I think I have to get rid of the
negative
Man, it's been a while
since war something
something.
learning. Yeah, this is reinforcement
learning. Dev
I'd have to like actually properly
practice to be able to communicate
usefully. It's kind of just a funny
white parlor trick at the moment.
Chinese student
didn't there's a lot of good RL in
China the game labs there kept going on
RL
um after like open AI stopped I guess
deep mind still has been doing game
stuff for a while they've still been
doing a lot of game stuff but they
definitely slowed down since like 2020
one. I can't imagine they're doing the
same amount and just publishing it less
because like there's not really a reason
you wouldn't publish like game RL
stuff.
Nest, I don't know what you mean by
nest. I want to learn more from you for
a while.
Is this what you
learned? I don't know what you mean by
We are currently working
on
vrace in
[Music]
buffer. Can the
hand is that
mistransated?
I figured that anchor learning was
mistransated as um is it reinforcement
learning or translation software in
China is not very good. It should
be. I think any of your uh any of your
language models should
work. Are they only trained on Chinese?
You guys should have multi like multi-
language models, right? Any of the
language models will do translation
pretty
well. I understand some of what you
said.
I try to speak
simpler. They're
uh it's hard to speak simply
about like reinforcement learning stuff
though. What is your technical
host. I'm guessing you're asking what my
job is.
law. In that case, it's research. Um,
what's
research? My goal is to make
reinforcement learning fast and simple.
Um, this is mostly science, scientific
research, engineering.
Yeah. Hey
Rogs. No. What's on the menu today?
We're working on uh VRay
implementation. Peanut here's like
giving me an impromptu Chinese quiz, but
other than that, we're
uh we're working on trying to get V
trace
working. Technology will be very popular
in China.
So, I ran competitions
uh and I think Netty's Netty's was and
Billy Billy uh they always entered them
and they always submitted some cool
stuff. B
trace B trace is
Impala. This is kind of a replacement
for generalized advantage
estimation. Um it's kind of
similar. The goal of it is to do off
policy correction.
Uh so if you have some old samples that
you're using for training, it should be
more stable than generalized advantage
estimation.
We're trying to use this to enable
buffer to add a replay buffer so we can
do a little bit of prioritized
experience replay.
Got it. But with PO, yes, it's possible
to have an experienced replay buffer for
online algorithms. That is what I'm
currently trying to figure
out. It's not exactly going to be a
replay buffer in the same sense for
offline. like we want most of the data
to be on policy, but the idea is we'd
like to at least be able to keep around
a few very high value trajectories,
things like very rare events and stuff.
Um, so I'm trying to see if we can get
off policy correction to work with that.
So, not a ton of stale data, but like a
little bit of stale
data. Okay. I mean, this now worked, but
this works worse than
before. So,
um what's it say the advantage is going
to
X. So this is the advantage
here that we computed, right?
I don't think this gets multiplied by
row. Where did I see that? This gets
multiplied by
row. I think I saw this from the
original.
Impala implementation
loss. They do this log solve max
thing. So this is not a clipable
ratio.
though. Yeah. So, this is where I got
the advantages from. They do clipped PG
rows
times
reward plus
gamma minus
like I'm going to clip it at myself,
right?
Hang
on. I'm planning on clipping this
myself. So, I think this
flipping. It's different because you're
clipping the advantage, not the ratio.
It's kind of weird. You
clip you clip the policy ratio but not
the
advantage. That doesn't really do
anything, right?
Yeah, this is definitely
better.
Um, this is still not doing what we
want.
I mean, it is
like it's not that far off,
That shouldn't mess anything
up. Be better with pryo than without
it. Okay. Okay. And if I take V trace
off, right?
E. So it does struggle a little bit, but
that does get above
70 and it goes up to
80. You know, I wonder if this is a
hyper thing though at this point,
parameter. Maybe you have to retune
Maybe it's just different now. So if I
do like 95
it. Oh yeah, there you
go. So it is
hypers. I think it is just hypers.
these. That would make sense, right? You
have the extra lambda parameter in GA
um which kind of forces you towards
more recent experience.
Okay. What value of return are you
aiming for? Like
80s. I think 80s generally is what I get
from my PO baseline. We're going to run
it live anyways. You'll see in a
because I don't like the way that they
do the loss in
um in
VR. I don't think it's a good way that
you do
loss. I think they're just missing the
clipping factor from
PO. Okay, this is actually Yeah, this is
a very solid solid
performance. That's like nice and stable
as well.
And now we'll do without V
trace which is now PO but this is PO
with 0.95
discount. So this might not be up. Then
we'll do with the the other
reward. Or it might just be way better
to be fair. That's also possible.
Okay. So, you outperform here. Not by a
massive
So now that we have the
that dialed
in, if I just don't do any of this
So this
is original
impala
You're not getting any normalization on
the
advantage. We'll let this run just to
see if it does something magical.
But I think the more likely is what if
we just norm and don't
clip. Is that a thing that we can
do? I think that if you norm then you
have to
clip. This actually does kind of catch
up.
What if you norm this
way? This probably breaks it,
right? Cuz now we're norming without
clipping. I mean, it it does
something. Yeah, but now it gets
unstable,
right? It was training and then it
crashes cuz you don't have the clipping
anymore. Not norming the advantage is
just
rough. That's a thing that's in clean,
isn't it?
Advantage
Dorm. I didn't just make that up,
here. Interestingly, it does it over the
mini
batch. Yeah. So, like it's
It just
can't not
stable. And then like you can do the
full clip
thing. We can
do we can do clip without norm. I don't
think this is good
though. I think you really need the
norm.
I'm letting this run in case it
converges
It's not like either of them just
doesn't work
well. You know, this kind of did catch
up
nicely, but just not as good
as the
norm. I mean, is it possible that we
have like learning rate differences now?
If I like fiddle with
right? Let's see if this still works on
breakout.
though, GA worked on
uh higher
gamma. Maybe we should run that
experiment next.
the breakout doesn't full solve
here, What
Okay, so that gets way close to a solve
right there. Just by doing
that, it's like almost a proper
solve. I think that would be too low
even for this.
um one is genuinely better or worse or
if
it's hyperparameter shenanigans going
on. I guess an equivalent would
be if we set lambda equals 1 for uh po,
right?
output would be a tensor that represents
a few control point
heights as if you would have to scrutize
the action
That does
work. Too
low. What is
um I got to look
up. I've been kind of iffy on the
horizon effective horizon of J because
like it's often one over one minus gamma
is how it's quoted but if you actually
look at the math
right you have this lambda smoothing
factor and these estimates get
discounted more and
more so I think it is kind of gamma
lambda so if it's gamma lambda is super
horizon then
085 that would seem a little odd to me
yeah but That's a full solve at 80
Hamza. Try 0.9 first. Let's look at some
of these curves.
So this is
like
[Music]
9.98.95. It could just be that there's a
difference in how horizon is computed
here. Like that would explain
it. Q function of both joints.
It's pretty cool.
Okay. So then this goes back to being
worse I
think. What happens if I just run
um without V trace with this form?
Does how sensitive is breakout? I mean
uh PO to
it. The V trace definitely works. I just
don't think it works better so far.
[Music]
good. Yeah, that's a very strong
baseline actually.
Right. This ends up
matching best run.
And then if you take this
off, you use the
original. Is it just the additional
lambda smoothing?
cannot quite
understand. Can you briefly tell? Yeah.
So I'm doing here this is VR. Well, no,
not this one. Hang on. This is P. This
is the generalized advantage estimation
used in
PO. So we have this advantage
function and then we have V trace which
is this alternative used in
Impala. And this function here is
supposed to make it easier to use off
policy
data without collapsing your
policy. So I have this implemented now.
I have a CUDA kernel for both and I'm
trying to see if I can get V trace to
match PO performance and then maybe be
better off
policy. But PO is just a very strong
baseline. It's just like always slightly
better. I guess one thing I can
technically do
here. What happens if I force J
lambda? This will probably mess it up,
right?
It is possible I suppose that
um the lack of the gamma par the lambda
parameter is going to mess it
like this should be Python's m machine
training
model. So here's the recursive form,
right? It's
lambda time
cs. Isn't this like this is really
really close? Oh yeah. So, not having
lambda totally screws up um VA. What
happens if I actually then set gamma
equals? I'm curious to see if that
breaks
still because it is kind of like using
lambda equals 1 with
trace. Hang on. It Let's just put these
up side by side.
Can you integrate a lambda pram with
vrace? Is that a thing that we could
just
do? Cuz like this is just an
exponentially smooth
estimate,
right? And then what are these deltas
like?
I watched it for a long time and I felt
it looked so
accumulating. What's this you're working
on? So, we have we have a CUDA kernel
for generalized advantage estimation. We
have a CUDA kernel for V trace. I'm
trying to see if I can outperform
generalized advantage estimation with V
trace because supposedly it should make
uh it should make our algorithm a little
bit more robust to off policy samples
and I want to integrate a small off
policy replay buffer with PO just so we
can keep around some very high value
trajectories. Okay, so this is actually
very interesting here, right? So what I
just
did these last two runs here, this is uh
J with original hypers but lambda set to
one and then this is 0.95 with lambda
set to one. So if you do not have a
lambda parameter for J, you're kind of
just screwed.
So, the fact that VRay doesn't have a
lambda
parameter is probably just going to make
it
worse. But I like what they do. What
they're doing with VRay fundamentally,
right? Level of capture is far below.
Sound cut is cut off a lot. Let me fix
that. I have this nice mic here.
suppression. I mean, I just have default
a default compressor and noise
suppression on this
thing. I could probably just do
this. That should probably be
better. Mic is probably just too
far. It's just in the frame.
Let me make sure it's got the right mic.
It
should. Yeah, that's the right
mic. Let me know if it's if this is
still screwing
Yeah, this is just annoying because it's
like now I literally have this right in
my face. But
whatever. I got to figure out with the
new setup. I'm going to have a um I'm
going to have more room to put stuff and
I got to figure out like what is a
better way to put a
microphone. I just have this like
mounted to the back of the desk and it's
just between my two monitors.
Okay. So, what I like
about what I like about
Vrace here, we need one more paper for
context
here. So, the main thing that PO does,
right? PO introduces
this. you get this ratio of pi uh pi
theta over pi theta old and then you
clip based on this.
Right? So what vtrace does essentially
is it threads this
estimate. It threads this estimate
through the advantage computation.
And actually, if I'm looking at this
Okay. They don't just They just don't
have this nice of a description of it
here written out. They have it like in
the paper
on. They have a whole bunch of math
here.
different. We don't have any more math,
right? Yeah. This is going to all be
results.
Let me see if from the original form I
can figure
out the
equivalence. I think it's pretty
close. It's really this formula right
here. So this is V
s. Yeah. So this is your gamma
pram. I think we should be looking at
this one.
What's this? Delta
T reward
plus
gamma minus
value. So this is the same right? this
term and I think you get roughly the
same telescoping effect
here.
Right? I I think you get the same
telescoping, don't
you? Maybe you don't quite because the
CIS are different. Maybe that's why this
is a little bit more complicated. But
this sum of deltas
Oh yeah, here gamma to the L's
delta. So this is gamma to the L
delta. They call it delta TV. This is
not uh this is not delta t *
v. And then I think that you add the
value to the advantage anyways, right?
that. Hang on. This is the target and
then you you add something to
this. We're going to figure this out
today. You're working for some company.
Puffer AI is my own
company. My goal is to make
reinforcement learning fast, sane, and
stable. All the stuff that I work on, I
do it all live. It's all open- source,
but uh companies can buy priority
service packages from us, which is
basically if you're doing reinforcement
learning and you're having a hard time
of it, you can uh get our eyes on your
problem, you can get custom puffer lip
features uh delivered very quickly and
you can get assistance integrating all
of our tools with your problems. So,
that's the only thing we sell.
All the code's open source. It's all
free. And it's generally we have a fun
time building cool stuff around here.
VS. It's seriously hard to work. But
yeah. Yeah, this is uh it's a lot of
work. It's a lot a lot of work. But I
mean, the goal here is and I think we're
really really close now. sane, stable,
consistent reinforcement learning across
the board. That would be like this just
huge huge thing. And it's actually it's
very close. It's not going to be some
like crazy framework with like a you
know hundreds of thousands of lines of
training code or anything. It's
literally just going to end up being a
few thousand lines of training code and
a bunch of really fast environments for
testing stuff.
But we have to get everything
right. And we're kind of at the stage
where it comes down to getting the
algorithms
correct. What mathematics you learn from
for ML and deep learning? Math is my of
all of my skill set, my math is by far
my weakest. I really didn't take very
much math. I took some linear algebra
courses, I guess. I took like whatever
discrete mathematics you get exposed to
just taking various different things in
AI. Um, but for the most part, when I
look at stuff like this, I just kind of
figure it
out. By far, um, my engineering
background is what I lean on the most
heavily. Uh, followed by just like lots
and lots of years of doing basic science
and getting good at it.
web developer working for a small
startup. What you think I can go for ML
now and how much time it takes to learn?
It's hard. It's easier than it's ever
been. Uh but it's still hard. I mean, I
started learning and like coding neural
nets when I was like 16 and uh I
published my
first paper I believe when I was
19 or so. So it took like three years to
be able to go from not knowing anything
to doing basic productive research. I
could do it a lot faster now because of
the resources that are available but
also the standard for publishing stuff
and like you know making good
contributions has gone up as well.
Um I mean you can if for reinforcement
learning specifically I've got a quick
start guide on puffer.ai AI that shows
what I suggest to new people for ML in
general. Like look at
CS231N. Uh it should be an easy course
if you have like the appropriate
background. It's not intended to be a
hard course. It's intended to teach you
things. And uh if you like really
understand everything in that course uh
then you probably understand more than
the majority of ML
engineers working professionally but
nowhere near as much as the really good
ones.
This subtracts values of
t. So this is t next minus values of t.
Why does it do
that? Wait.
this. Okay. So, you don't add it here.
Instead, you subtract it. So we remove
this, we subtract this, and then these
two are
equivalent. I don't
know. There's also this extra rewards of
T. It's kind of weird, isn't it? Oh,
this is cuz it's T next. Okay, so I
think that this is like a notational
difference. I think this is just pretty
much a notational difference.
Um if I have to go for agentic AI or
generative what do you
think I have to go through
ML but better I don't have a better
understanding of linear algebra and
calculus it's the same thing it's all
the same stuff like I could work in any
area of AI that I want and it would take
me like a few weeks at most to catch up
on all the literature. Um core
engineering skills are really
useful especially like ML engineering.
It's just it's all core engineering
skill. The fundamentals of deep learning
are the same anywhere you go. The types
of problems you'll be looking at and the
things that matter are different at
different scales. But like I could very
very very easily go from doing all this
like ultra fast infrastructure for tiny
RL models to doing like fast parallel
infrastructure for LLMs. It would not be
remotely challenging to go to like
almost the complete polar opposite
thing and I have I mean I've worked in I
started off in natural language
processing. I did some research in
vision. I got to RL. I did a bunch of
science there. I got more into the
engineering side. I built a bunch of
tools, right? I've done a bunch of
stuff. How many research papers do you
read per week? It depends what I'm
doing, right? When I'm building like
infrastructure and environment stuff,
zero. Now, like I'm not really reading
the full papers, but I'm like cross
referencing several papers in any given
week.
It really depends what you're doing
though, right? Like reinforcement
learning has been stuck for the last
five years. Like the papers that come
out came out last week or whatever, I
can virtually guarantee you without
reading them that they haven't made a
difference. So, it's not as much about
keeping current. It's more about drawing
the connections among all these things
and finding the things that people have
missed and being able to validate that
way more quickly and way more
exhaustively than anybody ever has
because I made puffer lib so fast that I
can run experiments a thousand times
faster than anybody else
Delta. I think if I figure out how to
integrate a lambda term with this, it'll
be
better. Shouldn't be monitoring paper
reading. Be focused on understanding.
go through papers with
LLMs. I mean, I use LLMs to sanity check
sometimes, but they're really wrong half
the time. They're like really wrong half
the
time. A good researcher is going to be
way better at finding useful stuff from
papers than an LLM every time.
So here's rewards minus next values
minus value. Right? So this is reward
minus plus value. No rewards plus next
value minus
value. Okay. So this was like your
delta, right?
Plus, maybe I can just like modify this
a little
bit. This is the hardest part of PO to
read. So Ryan, I'm uh I think what I've
realized here, VREC has
potential, but um not as it's
written. The lack of a lambda parameter
is really hindering it.
I'm trying to add a lambda parameter to
vrace
now. Can't modify the
horizon. It's just like an additional
weird It's like this weird doubly
exponentially smooth thing, right? Cuz
like the gamma is one exponential, the
lambda is
another. Apparently, there's some theory
behind that, but like I can tell you
empirically. So, Vrace does better than
PO if you have to fix lambda equals 1,
but it does a little bit worse
consistently if you are allowed to fix
like a more reasonable lambda for
PO. Nowadays, companies are hiring more
PhDs in math than CS or ML. What's your
take on it? Somebody's got to write the
code. If you're good at math and you
like math, then do math,
right? If you're like more naturally
like drawn to engineering, get good at
that. And then look for places where
there is value to be had, but people
with your skill set are not attempting
stuff in that area.
point of vrace was to let you use even
more off policy data. It is. So Ryan,
the way that I'm intuiting this right is
that if you think of standard discounted
return, APBO and Impala. Yeah. So I
think that the way to interpret this
Ryan is that they both start from this
formula right here. This is just
standard discounted returns with a value
baseline, right? And then GA attacks on
this additional lambda
smoothing and Impala attacks on uh a
clipped ratio, right, to control off
policyiness. Uh I think that what you
want is both of those.
add. What's a good name for this? Puff
advantage.
You're testing a standard PO
advantage. You're testing a standard PO with only minorly off policy data. I
with only minorly off policy data. I
don't want it to help. I just want it to
not be worse than J. And then what I
want to do is I want to use a off policy
replay buffer and have it not
catastrophically break the way that J
does, right?
Ryan. That seems like a reasonable goal,
right?
Settle for slightly
worse. Nah, that's just if you don't
know how to code,
man. I don't see why you would why it
would be any
worse. It should even just be better out
of the box if you think about it, right?
Because like PO gets slightly off policy
after the first mini batch
anyways. Most tricks aren't that
general. Good thing that I work a lot of
hours and can explore a lot of tricks,
right?
I literally was like woken up at 3:00 in
the morning today because I had some
algorithm
ideas. I couldn't fall asleep for a bit
cuz I was
Well, J isn't a magic bullet either,
right? It's just like some shitty thing
that's kind of hard to
beat. It's not like J is the like
optimal thing.
stood the test of time though with
everything being tuned around
it. Might want to run a big tuning
sweep. Yeah. Well, the cool thing is I
can do that, right? This is just like
preliminary dev.
You know, I've actually found PPO is
pretty dang robust with RMS. Like, yeah,
if you crank stuff down to 10 million 10
million steps and then you're like
cranking up the epochs and stuff, things
get unstable. But in our setup, it's
actually really surprisingly resilient.
like you get clean really clean curves
on a lot of the simpler M with a pretty
wide range of hypers. Muon helped cosine
and healing helped. Like we've really
really made RL a lot easier than uh the
RL you're thinking
of. It actually feels like working in a
different field since we added all the
new stuff. Like it no longer feels crazy
cursed. Like a lot of things kind of
just make sense.
Like a month and a half ago, I would
have agreed with you. You literally
couldn't do anything without rerunning a
full hypers sweep. Now you kind of can.
You can't do everything without
rerunning hypers, but you can actually
do a lot.
I have to take your word for it. I want
to jump on puffer train this summer.
Yeah. I'm telling you, man. I've been
working my ass off to get this field
into a decent
place. I think the next few months are
just going to be like the crucial get
everything into
place and then I'm going to see from
there. There's so much more to do. I'm
actually thinking of doing some
modelbased stuff soon. I know that's
crazy, but I was thinking about it and
like I think I have a use case for
it. One of the big things I want you to
be able to do with puffer, right? I want
you to be able to literally just take
the hyperparam sweep algo, right? and
just change the x-axis that it cares
about, the cost axis from uh wall clock
to steps and get either ridiculously
sample efficient RL or ridiculously fast
wall clock RL. Just out of the box, your
[ __ ] is solved. Done. No more demons, no
more garbage. Fields freaking solved.
Done. And then I will move on to other
things. probably using RL to solve like
every outstanding RL industry problem
that I can get my hands
on
probably dreamer like architecture. I
don't like that they reconstruct the
inputs
fully. That's really obnoxious for
complex ob spaces.
So, we're going to have to see about
that. Um, but I've been like thinking
about how I would do
that. I really should just start
sponsoring some bounties for stuff. I
just
um Yeah, I got to figure out financially
like I'm sort of waiting until I buy all
the hardware first cuz that's going to
be a big
expense. Supervised learning step is a
big reason why it works though. Yeah, do
the supervised learning step. We want
the supervised learning step.
Right. Supervised auxiliary losses are
good. I've learned that
recently. You could do supervised on
hidden state differences,
guess. Yeah. So, I think that you'd want
something like that. I also think that
we have a candidate for replacing
entropy bonus in the works. I think it's
very, very likely we have just a better
entropy bonus.
Um, a lot of stuff's coming together and
it's just
like I need to pull some crazy hours to
make it all work over the next few
weeks, but I only really have this week
because I got I'm going to the new
facility I think after this week and
then there's going to be some setup
time. They don't train the world model
with RL at all. Seems like we should be
able to do end to end RL. I actually
don't agree on that.
Um because I recently I got the chance
to like see the difference between
adding an auxiliary loss as an
additional RL objective versus as an
additional supervised objective. I
actually nowadays I kind of think that
you want to just keep RL on the reward
and not mess with the reward function in
any way whatsoever.
um like with auxiliary loss terms and
just have all the auxiliary losses be
supervised. If you can do it that way,
it makes it way easier and then you
don't end up like shifting the, you
know, the optimal reward objective and
stuff like that.
I also really like stuff where um you
only have to compute it in the train
step. I think what we want is we want to
make the eval step really really cheap
so that um you know when we collect new
data we can throw away whatever is like
low advantage or whatever or we can
crank up stuff like world model steps or
stuff like you know value function
iterations whatever in order to get
sample efficiency on
it. Hey searchers, how's it
going? Okay, so this now runs. We got to
add lambda to
right? Not talking about changing
reward. I think we should be able to ch
train the world model to learn task
specific features.
Task Pacific still transit generalist.
Um task there was I actually had some
like I think one of the things you'll
like I was working on Diane the other
day
and you actually can get policies to do
different stuff like one policy to have
different behaviors conditioned on some
additional input. Uh, and there's a way
to do it supervised, which is kind of
cool. There might be a way to do what
you want
supervised, working on all my favorite
methods, but I'm trying. It is like, it
is a
lot. I've got like way too many things
floating around in my head at the
moment, but it is exciting.
what's context of today's discussion. So
what I'm doing at the moment here which
is slightly different than what we're
discussing with Ryan. This
is so on the right we have vrace and on
the left we have generalized advantage
estimation here. Um they both build off
of discounted
returns
and the issue is J adds a lambda
parameter for an additional exponential
smoothing. VR adds uh this importance
measure for off policy
correction in context where you don't
have super off policy data. Vrace
slightly underperforms J. So I'm trying
to add a lambda parameter to vrace so we
just get like the good advantage
function to use that is stable and that
lets us do off policy correction. Ryan,
all you have to do to get me on board
for net hack is figure out how to run it
at a reasonable batch size. Like there's
the annoying threading stuff with net
hack, right? It like the base C code is
fast, right? It should run millions of
steps per second. I believe if you can
just get that thing to run like a batch
of at least 500 m ideally like 20 48 ms
or 4096 m we can just do net hack and I
will be absolutely down to do
that. That's the issue with net hack.
It's like fast but it's not fast bashed
for RL as far as I've
seen. If you get it running fast back
with puffer, we will gladly use that as
like an awesome awesome baseline.
M bottleneck by grads. It is not
bottlenecked by grad. It's only
bottleneck by grabs because of the
stupid baseline architectures. You can
very easily use the like the pixel
wrapper or whatever. Like there's like a
C++ wrapper that just converts the
characters to be like a a pretty
reasonable size multi-channel 2D array.
We would be able to throw our standard
architectures on that and it wouldn't be
bottlenecked.
We should be able to do net hack at
hundreds of thousands of steps per
second. We really
should architecture not m I think it's
both. I think it's both because I
haven't timed it. You would have to time
it, right? But I'm pretty sure when I
did net
I don't have the paper
link. Mulib runs thousands of MS all at
once. Get it to work, man. Just get it
to work. I'll help you.
Like, here. Look, this is what I'm
saying, right? Puffer Live now exists.
Training can be made fast if you don't
if all the other things that are
currently slow that didn't used to
matter actually are done correctly. I
got it to 100K before, I believe.
100k if we can get it. The end has to
run at the end has to run at least a few
hundredk. I'm just beginning these stuff
like just nose gradient descent and all.
How much time does it take and what's
the job market requires you to do? I
mean, I've been doing this stuff for
half my life. What can I say, right? Um,
if you're interested in RL
specifically, I've got this quick start
guide here. It's a much more accessible
guide than everywhere else pretty much.
It's a lot less math. It's like a short
number of resources. So, I'd suggest
this if you don't have an ML background.
In general, though,
CS231N definitely is a good thing to do.
Um, I mean, it doesn't take that long if
you like really get stuck into it to
like start doing useful research. I will
say 100K is enough, man, for me. I'm
making progress at 20 to 40k depending
on the
method. Yeah, but like you're making
progress, but you haven't felt the
difference, right, between doing
research at that speed and doing the
research at puffer speeds. I can tell
you it's a massive difference. Like we
just straight up trivialize things that
would be months of research because we
don't have to be smart. I don't have to
be smart about stuff. I just run all the
experiments, right? It's kind of like
the equivalent of being of having access
to an industry cluster with hundreds of
GPUs and just running everything. It's
like that except you can do it without
even the infrastructure cuz all our
stuff is just fast. Following Andrew Ang
and Andre Carpathy. Go watch Carpathy's
231N lectures on YouTube. They're all on
YouTube. That's the best that is the
best uh general deep learning course as
far as I've
seen. I generally tell people like who
are new, you spend like 20 30% of your
time on formal learning like that. Um,
and then you build stuff. You build lots
of stuff. So, a lot of the contributors
to Puffer Lib who built all these M's
here. Like here's a good example for
you. This environment was built by
somebody who came in with zero
reinforcement learning experience, zero
programming experience, and zero
relevant math experience uh one year
ago. So this guy got to the point where
he could do this and get a superhuman
model on a hard M that he built in less
than a
year. He worked really hard
though. Like it's not going to be easy.
You can do it. It's absolutely doable.
But don't expect it to be easy.
I mean, we help people out around here
as much as we can,
right? Especially all of our puffer
contributors. But yeah, it's not it's
not going to just be straight up easy.
You definitely have to put in work.
I mean, better is better. I can do a lot
at current speeds. I take a 5x speed up.
I'm happy to spend some time on
optimization. I'd be worried about
gutting the model for
speed. Yeah. So, that's valid. Um, but
like
Ryan, Neuralarmmo has a 3.1 mil perm
model that runs at 500k.
Right. We do end to end neural MMO 3.1
million paramps, not even compiled or
anything. 500 to
600K. I think it's actually 500ish now
that we made it
like 3.1 mil. But
still, what's your opinion on vibe
coding? Don't Yeah, just don't do that.
You're not going to learn anything.
You'll notice that when I'm typing, I
have single line autocomplete for the
most part. Like I'm not like I'm not
just writing like write a function that
does this and have it fill it in. It's
but mostly I just use it to make myself
type faster and fill in boilerplate.
this. I would say use LLMs as a learning
tool, but honestly like lately they
haven't even been that useful for that
for me. Like, yeah, for basic stuff, but
once you get to a certain point, they're
just wrong half the
time. Net hack agents only beat like 5%
of the game. So, it's not like we're
optimizing a full solution at this
point. Yeah, I have the same thing with
neural MMO, though, right? It's more
like 20% or whatever, but
still, you want to be able to do this
this iteration cycle fast.
Okay, so this runs now. This should
match previous Perf, I would
assume. I do it for making prototypes
for hackathons, reading code, structure,
and editing. I don't even suggest doing
that,
man. Like, I don't suggest ever getting
the thing to give you a full prototype
cuz like it's going to make it'll build
like the initial thing wrong. You really
want to be the one thinking about your
data structures, how you're going to set
stuff
up. The only time I say, yeah, use it to
prototype is if you're working with like
a new library that you don't know the
API of and you just need something to
get you like correct calls to a new
API. We should chat about Net Hack
sometime. I'm going to spend some time
on it this summer. So, if we can make it
work with Puffer, that would be sweet.
Yeah, I will be happy to support that.
And uh by summer, hopefully we should
have compute for you as well. It
actually depends on tariffs at this
point. So, I'm basically I'm waiting for
the machine prices to go I'm waiting for
the tariff thing to get fixed. So, the
machine prices go back down to like
5,000 something a box ideally under
6,000 a box. Uh cuz I have to buy 40 of
them. So, that's a big purchase. And I
do not want them to be over 6,000 a
box. They don't know I've graduated.
That works. Yeah, that
works. But the new facility, like I will
be going to the new facility and staying
there in a week or two.
right. I think that we need last puffer
lamb,
right? Got to do some work. See you. See
you, Ryan.
plus. So what if we do last puffer lamb
is going to be
gamma time lambda *
ct* last puffer lamb time next non-
right. Insane. Bro, you did PhD from
MIT. How's your
experience? PhDs are hard and really
obnoxious.
Um, I had a bunch of time to like
develop a whole bunch of tech.
Um, I definitely couldn't have done the
same thing in industry. I mean, it's
good
overall, but
um, I mean, there's definitely a reason
I'm not in academia anymore, right? I
like what I'm doing now, which is doing
way less constrained research.
Um, and then the only thing is I have to
figure out how to monetize things,
right? Which is like that adds more
work, but I think it that adds less work
than academia ads in
general. And it's like you're hardly
getting paid. I mean, the PhD is good is
the thing. The PhD is good. It like it
opens a lot of doors. Um, but it's not
just it's not all good, right? Like
dealing with academia is a total total
pain. Okay, this actually looks kind of
good here. Hang
easy? Should check this a few different
ways.
So, this should work with these params
if I did it
right. And it should crash horribly if I
didn't.
it? I think that's
good. Wait, that's really good, isn't
it?
Guys, we solved
it. We freaking solved
beautiful. I can tell this is going to
be it. This is going to be the first
like major puffer algorithm contribution
right here. I like this has to be.
There's no way, right?
Let's
see. This is just breakout. It like it's
such a stupid little test end, but it's
like it's got to be this. There's like
almost no way it wouldn't
be. It's like so obvious in retrospect,
right?
see. It doesn't have to be straight up
better. It just has to match.
matches. It's actually a little above
even. Okay. Yeah, we're
good. We expect it to be the same, maybe
slightly better. And this is what it
Just getting this for the baseline
versus original V
trace. Get out of here,
bot. I write the bots here. Way too many
Twitch bots.
Okay.
So this line here
vrace brown line
J blue line puffer
advantage. Note that this was tuned for
this one. So this is the best possible
case as well for
uh J. So, we can potentially do even a
little better with
this, but uh it's not supposed to
necessarily immediately be way better.
It's supposed to be more stable. So,
we'll have to test that next.
Let's hope it works on Snake
next. How do you look Chinese
innovations like
Manis, Gem, Spark, and Leading Deep
Seek? I don't follow like LLM stuff in
general very much, honestly. Right.
I know in RL they have good
stuff like cuz Netis and Billy Billy
have done stuff on our competitions in
the
past. Oh, this is train use vrace,
right? So now we got to
do train
use. Oh, that's uh hang on. That was
vrace with vrace params.
So now what we do is we
go back to uh whatever these were these
baseline. I mean there's really not much
point in me following closely all this
LLM stuff, right? Like look what's going
to happen is all these top labs are just
going to leaprog each other every couple
months until one of them
wins and probably not like one of them
isn't going to just win anytime soon
because they keep swapping people back
and
forth. Yo, you implementing that paper
from
yesterday? Oh man, the one from
yesterday was a pain in the ass and
didn't really work. We do have a awesome
result today though. Uh we have a new
advantage uh advantage estimation
function in puffer. Brand new research
J. Yeah. So actually original vrace is
going to do about the
sameish because uh I think that's just
hyperparam difference. That's H param
diff. Damn. Yeah, it's
cool. So I implemented what happened
here is I implemented CUDA kernel for J.
I implemented CUDA kernel for
vrace and then I realized that you can
put these two algorithms together very
very cleanly with like one extra line of
Buddy.
match.
So what do we run this
on? I mean we have to run this on off
policy correction now,
right? How do you pick these research
papers? Like is it random or are you
following
someone? No, it's not
random. It's basically like I don't know
every paper out there, right? I know a
lot of the major papers though they just
come up repeatedly if you're in
reinforcement learning for a while and I
connect the
dots. So I spent a long time recently
looking through the details of J GA
because I was trying to work on uh
advantage
estimation and then I spent some time on
the impala formula because I was looking
at off policy
correction and then if you look very
closely at these even though they're
notated very uh they're notated quite
differently you actually see that the
code the implementation is virtually
identical and that there's a very clean
way to put them
together. So the next thing we have to
check and this is going to be harder and
actually I don't know if this is even
going to work out of the box because the
implementation might be bugged. Um but
we wanted to do off policy
correction. I think we want to go to
mazes. Mazes is our best bet for
Same guy wrote poly
time mvin
torch just finished writing the same in
see
awesome any code for me to look
at I think it's well how was how was it
first of all how was it uh porting
Writing loops was refreshing. Yeah, it
is, isn't
it? Isn't it great to not have to warp
your brain to think about everything as
a freaking array operation for no
reason?
I'm telling you, Jacks for I guess for
like some robotic stuff if you need the
M to run on the
GPU and even then like you should be
writing CUDA or whatever. But um yeah,
generally like jacks for M is just
researchers not knowing how to write
anything other than
Python. Like everybody just got on like
everybody just got off the bus on the
wrong stop.
after every freaking operation is a
vectorized. Yeah, I'm well aware. Oh,
I'm well aware of how that game
goes. I mean, that is that is actually
what Jack says, though. Like,
researchers did not know how to write
code and then this thing came along and
they got off the bus at the wrong stop.
function. Man, I hate functional
programming. Like, as much as I hate
object-oriented programming, I hate
functional programming every bit as
much. It's just like two idiotic camps
of dogmatists fighting over who can
write shittier code.
It's just like, guys, did you know
programming can be
easy? Did you know that programming
doesn't have to suck?
This is going to be our
baseline. And then when I run the next
experiment, which will be um puffer
advantage, I'm going to go take a few
minutes while it runs. Use a rest room,
grab a drink, all that. And then we will
look at the results. And hopefully we
don't get uh any nasty surprises on
this. But I think we should be okay.
We will
see cuz this is a pretty clean this is
like a pretty clean learn curve for this
task,
clean. Kind of levels off right around
70%.
huh? Let's see
why. That doesn't make any sense.
There are some bugs with this end. So
like we're not going to just
be we're not going to just say all the
algorithm's
wrong. We got clear-cut results on two
Ms.
Does this reproduce on any other
end? It's actually what I want to do
first. I'm not confident in that grid.
We're going to look at that next cuz
like breaking async is really bad.
Okay. So, this doesn't make any sense to
me at
this. Let's start with uh with breakout
stuff here. So actually this is
multipprocess.
difference. Yeah. So this thing just
like jumps to a solve.
Perfect
solve. It's
these? Can I just
like just look
take this version
here? So this is how it is
implemented. This is how it is
implemented.
It's kind of embarrassing.
that
um you know I spend like two days on
this and it ends up literally being a
oneline difference between these
algorithms. But this is what happens
when papers are using completely
different notation for everything,
right?
fail. Um, the only difference here is
row and
CT between these two algorithms, unless
I've screwed something else up. So,
let's just do that.
We remove
row. Then we remove
Okay, so the fact that this still fails
means that there's an externality
because these are now the same
code. This delta is identical, right?
Let's just double check that the code is
identical.
We're going to get this today, guys.
This is going to be the enduring
algorithm contribution we've been aiming
for for months. It's happening
today. Rewards T
next. So, technically there is this T
next
difference. We should check that, right?
this.
No. Okay. There's an externality.
There's definitely something
different between the way these are
being computed then.
You compute this using the
original the original values.
bit. We can make the sampling equal to
J and then the actual computation
better.
all when you realize the
um Okay, this is going to get simpler.
This is going to get simpler then.
importance
advantages sample by
No, that's
correct. Yes.
Advantages. You would know if it were
backwards.
There's like almost no way that this
doesn't help. The more that I'm thinking
about it, this has got to be
implementation errors. This idea is like
spot
on. This is like bulletproof.
It's going to be exactly equivalent to
J
here and it's going to add an importance
cut
off elsewhere.
welcome. We are working on a new
advantage estimation
algorithm for puffer lib.
Okay, so that still doesn't
work. What happens if we just comment
all of it? All of
this,
right? If we just comment this
block, we still get this
tube. It should end up exactly
equivalent to J if we're
careful. Okay. So, let's
see. This is batched advantages batched.
Advantages. Where are you from? I am
from the US.
Okay, so there's definitely an
externality because this code should
now we've now gotten to the point where
it should be identical.
help. Well, this is identical.
What am I doing? This is a new advantage
function for
uh reinforcement learning. It is a
combination of Impala's V trace and
generalized advantage
estimation. This should once I get it
right be
a pretty big performance boost for
puffer lip.
Yeah. So, we now have all this
identical. There's no like extra set,
right? Yeah. Okay. Code's
identical. So, now we just have to look
at here.
Oh, I obviously that's
broken. Let's
do whatever the one up here was. So,
this is T next.
So this should
work and then we have to compare.
trains and that is about the PF that we
got before.
Okay, this
trains and this actually now
does Yeah, about the
same.
Good.
So now we go back to clean
puffl and we figure out whether this
recomputation was messing us up.
similar. Well, you don't need to really
redo this at
all, come to think of it.
ratio. So the ratio could
get we could put this ratio up
So we do
this and
then this up here goes to experience
ratio. Let's see if that messes anything
up.
actually improves it a little
bit.
Okay. So, I mean, this is
like we're getting to the point where
this is reasonable, I'd say.
So now we have the custom
Just make sure it's
not
this. We shouldn't be able to just fail
like this.
Okay. Well, we can we have options here,
right? So, first of all, we try without
this. Yeah, we see it starts optimizing
pretty quick, right?
Okay. So now we
go we go
right. Okay. So this this two line
difference.
Now, let's actually try something cuz
I'm not sure about this change.
Words of
T. So I thought
that this TX was a bug.
bug. Yeah, cuz this doesn't train now.
Okay, so that's the difference.
Okay. So, probably what was happening
here, right, is like stuff like breakout
is not very sensitive to moving the
reward by
one, whereas any end that just gets a
terminal reward is going to be
I wonder if it does any
better long term or if it just like gets
there
faster. That might be model capacity
limited though to be
fair. And that's a little
higher. We'll see.
This is a
win. This is a big win. Holy
This is a really, really big win
today. Welcome YouTube
folks. I'm going to explain what we just
did. This is going to be Puffer's first
enduring algorithmic contribution. I
think um this
replaces this combines two of the most
commonly used
uh advantage functions and it's just
better first real quick since we do have
a few folks watching all my work here
this is all open source this will be in
the repo later today puffer.ai AI. If
you want to help me out for free, just
start the repo. We're almost at 2K. It's
going to be awesome. And you can get
involved with the devs on the Discord
right here as well. So, let me explain
what I just did. So, this is generalized
advantage
estimation. This is the basis of well,
one half of PO, the other half being
clipping. This is if that's PO here it
is. This is Impala and this is the
Vtrace target.
This is an off policy correction
mechanism. That is the other very
commonly used
algorithm. I noticed that these two
things kind of work
together. This is the base discounted
return with value baseline. It's like
bootstrap here. Uh that is used by both
algorithms.
Generalized advantage estimation adds to
this exponential smoothing over lambda
over like these
segments. VRE adds a uh
clamped policy ratio basically adds the
thing from PO but adds it into the
advantage computation itself rather just
in rather than as a um just a clamp on
the final
ratio. So all I did was
use exponentially smooth lambda and have
this
clamp. And lo and behold, the two best
known advantage functions stack
perfectly. And with this, we can kill
off vrace and we kill generalized
advantage
estimation. This is the new advantage
function.
Obviously, I need to do more testing,
but I I don't see a world in which this
doesn't. These results don't generalize.
And to give you an idea, by the way, uh
this is not just 10% better.
The this is doing better at the hardest
mazes here, cuz the mazes get harder.
So, it's like very very difficult to
reach 100%. Cuz that means you have to
solve all the easy mazes and all the
hard mazes. So this is like a big gap on
the hardest problems in this
set. Now the one thing we want to
here? So now this will actually allow it
to compute the advantage using the
updated experience ratio.
I don't know if this will be better or
worse for sure. It should be better, but
I wouldn't be surprised if it's
worse. And then after this test, we will
commit this stuff cuz this is major
discovery.
This really at the end of the
day was something really simple and
really
obvious, but it wasn't simple and it
wasn't obvious and like it hasn't been
done before as far as I know because
even though these two papers do
something like that's very very clearly
compatible, they use completely
different mathematical notation that
makes it very
nonobvious that they're doing the exact
same
does. And then the cool thing is we get
to test we get to test off policy stuff.
Now, even if the off policy stuff
doesn't work, we still win. But
technically, this should allow us to do
off policy stuff.
Okay, these curves are like right on top
of each other for now. We'll see if
there's any difference longer
term. It's only 2 p.m. We still have
lots of time today to test
stuff. It feels so good to actually
finally
have a breakthrough on this stuff. It
ends up being the simplest things, too.
It's almost never the case that you come
up with something incredibly complicated
that's just generally
I don't know if this kills the need for
P30, which was the other project I was
working on in um on advantage
functions. I think there's still a
possibility we'd get stuff from
there. But as like a
first thing, this is solid. And this is
like my goal was one of my major goals
with this next release is to make an
enduring contribution an enduring
algorithmic contribution to RL because
you know we get the criticism very
often. Oh, you're just kind of like, you
know, cobbling things together and doing
the engineering to make them fast, which
is like not really a criticism because
that was the major thing holding back
RL. But now I want to show people like
look with all this stuff that we've
built, we can actually make algorithmic
advancements
too. And uh it's actually a lot easier
for us because these tests here would
take days that I'm just running casually
while I'm chatting here. These tests
would take
days in any other reinforcement learning
library.
We run them in
minutes and it's much
easier. Never close the
stream. I was just sending emails and
proof reading. This looks really good.
Well, I mean, you got to uh you got to
see an algorithm breakthrough in RL made
live. This kills J though arguably it's
a oneline change to VR and it's also a
oneline change to J. So
like it's very related but this is like
hey look if you can make a oneline
change to V ge and call it v trace then
I can call this a new algorithm as
contribution and these look about as
good
right? Yeah, these are about on
par. What's the hardest M I can throw
this at right now?
Um, if you give me a second, I can
probably toss this at neural MMO
3, but I have to plug I have to without
a ton of code. Neural MMO
I love that you're using Abuntu. What
else would I be using? When you get the
chance, do you mind sharing the code
difference
between Yep. I have three CUDA kernels.
Isn't that nice? It's very simple. So,
here's the thing. It like the math for
these two papers is written very
differently, but they're identical. I do
have to check this T next thing but I
can confirm that using T does not work.
So I think that this is correct. I just
don't know why yet. So anyways, this was
our original GA
implementation. Okay, it's delta reward
next reward gamma time values of next uh
terminal and then values of t and then
you make your uh lambda par here.
There's delta plus exponentially smooth
gamma lambda terminal last J lambda. So
this is
J and then
here where is
it? This is V trace. So V trace is just
GA but you have this uh row par well
it's G without lambda and you have this
row here which is a clip a clipping
parameter.
And then you have this clipping
parameter
here. And then puffer
advantage is
just you have row and you have lambda.
So it is clipped via policy
ratio and it is exponentially smooth
with
nice. If I plug this Ethernet cable in,
I should be able to
um get
my this run
working. Is it exactly a mix of both?
Yep, it's exactly. If you think of J is
adding exponential smoothing to um like
discounted returns, right? Because
that's what J does. Adds exponential
smoothing with lambda to discounted
returns. Vrace adds clipping to
discounted returns. And um puffer
advantage does
both. It's exactly
both. Adds zero additional
hyperparameters over GE as well because
you kind of just always clip with uh
coefficients of one. Though I guess I
could test that. Let me plug this in.
I got to get under this desk to do that.
One second.
Wait, if that's it, I can try throwing
it at
Netlack. AO already uses VR. Yeah, you
can. We also ship our own CUDA kernel.
So, you can grab this CUDA kernel if you
want. You need like latest CUDA dev and
stuff. You need CUDA dev to compile.
How many hours you work a day and is
there any team behind your company? Uh,
it varies. I try to aim for like 60 70 a
week. That's about what I can sustain. I
really would like to get more, but
that's about what I can do. I mean, I
pretty much if I'm
not if I'm not exercising, eating, or
sleeping, I'm probably working.
um six six days a week. That's true. Six
and six six and a half. Um is there any
team behind your company? So there is a
big open source and then I bring in uh
we sell priority service project
packages to companies and then I bring
in PhD students and graduated PhDs just
buddies of mine uh to work on specific
contracts for specific clients.
So that's how the uh company
works. I don't know how to use CUDA
colonel so I'll be lazy. I can run five
seats stance and either result.
Awesome. Cool.
It's a pretty simple modification here.
But this was not simple to come up with
because
like the thing is even the
implementation of vrace like the
reference implementations of vrace are
very different from the reference
implementations of GA because the math
in the papers is written different
differently even though it's identical.
I know you need to write everything in a
similar form. Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
So, like this took
me like multiple days. Like arguably
this took me two full days worth of work
um for a oneline change. But like it was
because they looked really different at
the start and then they slowly looked
more similar as I kept implementing
stuff and then finally towards the end I
saw
it. Arguably, I probably could have seen
it faster um if my math background were
better, but like we got there,
right? And somehow everyone else missed
it
too. Close to a similar finding with
Aaron's curriculum algorithms. I think
we can write a unified version of LP and
PLR that uses the best features of both.
That would be
awesome. And to write these algorithms
into the same form for syllabus. Yeah,
that stuff's hard. I don't know when the
last time you chatted with Aaron is, but
we've got like a pretty good
implementation of LP uh that we're
looking to start testing out very soon.
Oh, we actually get the whole rest of
the training curve for this run. This is
good.
He's kept me roughly in the loop.
Good. Let's take a quick look at this
run cuz this was the old form of
prioritized experience replay. I think
it like did better initially, but then
it did worse after.
Good day for
buffer. How how close are we to 2,000
1950. 1936. Come on, guys. We are like
14 stars off.
Start the repo if you
haven't. That's so nice. Spinning up my
GitHub bot. Now, we don't want botch. We
want like actual people. But, uh,
they're definitely some botted RL
repos like this thing.
First of all, they took my damn package
name that I wanted cuz like puffer fish
and
fins. And like this piece of crap has
11,000 stars and it runs at like no SPS
at
all dev road map. It's just
like like what? This is generated by
GPT2 or something like laring as a
finance high
schooler.
plots? It's a lot of
data. It's trying to synchronize all the
extra data for this last one here. Yeah,
this one like leveled off. So, I think
we got to tune prioritize replay a
little bit, but uh hey, this is still
pretty
awesome. It has a bunch of runs it needs
to sync somehow.
Oh, it's like slowly syncing more data.
That's
funny. It's like iteratively syncing in
a loop, I
guess. Okay, we'll let this synchronize
a little bit and then what we're going
to do is we're going to queue up this
new algorithm on neural MMO 3. We'll
just let it run and then we will uh do
some work cleaning up and testing the
main
repo so that we can work towards getting
this all this stuff like stable into
dev. I mean technically speaking right
we still have to do a little offline
testing even if that horribly fails
doesn't matter. we've already
won.
Um, like algorithmically we're kind of
good for next release now. Like I can do
more stuff, but this is enough now to
merit like a new major version release
because we have integrated lots of stuff
from other areas, right? We got muon, we
got cosine kneeling, we got a few other
improvements that make a major
difference that people are not commonly
using in
RL and that gives us a huge PF
difference. We've got way more stable
hyperparam stuff. Now we've got protein
which is our custom hyperpar sweep
algorithm and now we have this plus the
new M.
So, literally, it could be it could just
be clean everything up, get the new M
in, get the new Oh, and the new binding
infrastructure. Get the new binding
infrastructure in and ship it. And
that's like honestly with this, if this
works on Nurmo 3, I'm willing to call it
a 300
big. Maybe a tuning sweep. Of course,
we're going to tune
Puffer advantage
trademarked. Yeah, we'll think of if uh
if we've got another name for
it. Generalized puffer
traces. Now we'll come up with something
good. Is this just sinking very slowly?
I think it is just sinking very
slowly. I It's a lot of data. Okay, let
me use the restroom real
quick. This will run. We're going to
queue up this new experiment. And if
this is going to take forever to sync,
we'll just start messing with stuff in
the meantime while it sinks. Be right
back.
optimization. I don't know. We'll come
up with
something. Yeah, I think this is just
sinking super super slowly because it's
a lot of data.
So, we're just going to leave that
there and we can do some stuff now. So,
first thing I want to do is this TX next
thing. I want to figure that
out. Make sure we uh we don't have
something weird
there.
So, this is
next. It looks like in the formula here
it's pretty clearly t next.
Is there
something I'm missing with
this? Cuz this breaks training.
Oh, this could just be a difference in
the way that we collect our experience,
right?
It is a it would be good to understand
what the heck is different here.
So here in this formula right it has
reward at T
RT. Let me think if there's a way the
reward could be defined
differently. I mean, does it make sense
that this could be due to vectorzation
differences like
You know, you collect obs and then you
see reward, but you pad zero versus
right. I can't think of what else would
cause this type of stuff because it
clearly doesn't work with reward at
T. There's no issue. It's just like
there's a discrepancy between how I have
this and also how I had my original GA
implemented and how it is in the math
here. So here they have reward at time
step t and I have reward at time step t
+ one and it doesn't work in this
version. Uh it doesn't work with reward
at time step t. I tested that with both
J and V
trace I guess. Yeah, if they let me see
where they define
reward. So they define it on state
action state
triples. So probably yeah there's just a
uh it's probably just a difference here
in how uh we've had you get a zero
reward on
reset. If you get it wrong, you end up
with a slight bias. Well, you see it
very clearly in M's that have like just
a reward at the end or whatever because
if you're off by one, it doesn't
learn. But like I can clearly tell you
that it doesn't work if you use reward
at time step t like they have in the
paper. So I think what it is is that in
their case uh they don't pad a zero
reward. They don't get a zero reward at
reset. So they're observation at reset
is lined up with the first reward in the
experience buffer. Like that's how
they're doing their notation.
So, I'm almost positive that's what it
is.
reward. Yeah. And that messes up your
buffer a bunch,
right? I think that you do need to give
a reset reward otherwise you mess up
your buffer.
you don't need to have this like
separate VS now
Well, the one thing that is off with our
implementation, Ryan, is um we do not
get the final
value. Like there's this annoying piece
of code that people write like they go
through the network again just to get
the value function. We just cut it one
short. So you just don't get you just
basically you lose one sample off the
end because you didn't do one extra pass
through the net. So same
thing you'll just get zero advantage for
um the
end. Okay. So I think that what we want
to do here
is remove this advantage
thing or this VS thing. Yeah, we remove
VS. Extra value prediction is a pain.
Yeah, it is right. There's no point
either.
something. Yeah, you don't need VS at
all here.
And do
I I seed it with values of horizon minus
one
right. Yeah. You know what? This is
right because you never use the reward
at time step
zero. Yeah. This this is the thing. you
get rid of this. You never use the
reward at time step zero because you're
like that is the reward of the
previous one,
right? You only use that for the value
Okay. All we got to do is remove
um BS from
here. Oh, did we already get rid of BS
from
here?
Let's clean up our implementations a
little bit here.
stuns. Oh, yeah. This is all
different. That's
okay. We'll get to that.
I'm going to sleep well
tonight and then gotten this
done. It's a successful
uh successful discovery.
Right. Let's make sure we actually have
this stuff still working. You
That's kind of crazy, guys. That is kind
of
crazy.
Oh, hello
soda. Well, it's a good thing that uh we
got this whole phrase cuz that's soda by
another big margin.
does. Soda neural MMO 3 policy from the
previous stuff we were
testing. And
um now this new
stuff. That's pretty cool.
says 32
and.5 mil. Yep, that's on
par. I'll let this finish just so we see
final. But
um that's good so far. So that's a nice
clean up.
I think we'll uh let's get the CPU one
working as well, just so we don't have
to do it later.
values, rewards, dons,
importance,
seven. It's about on par. We'll
see. I make sure that this actually does
the same as
before. Does this knob seem a little
low?
low. Oh, maybe I ran without
um Well, we'll see how I ran this.
No, I did use the advantage function
here. Is that a
degradation? Shoot. Now we have to
actually go back and double check,
right?
This better not just be seed variance,
but I have not seen major seed variance
on this
Let's run it and track
it. Let's see. Maybe I just
misread. That's a big soda difference
there.
I thought we had more long runs than
this as well, didn't
we? I could have sworn we had more long
runs than
this. Might have to like change the
metric or whatever.
Okay. So, there is some seed variance,
but every single run I've done of of
this has still been significantly better
than 70, which was the old one. So, it's
still better.
So even if it's half this gap, it
doesn't matter. That's still a huge
difference on
average. But I think it's more likely to
be closer to this because this was I
mean I've had four runs. So average
would suggest like 2/3 of this maybe.
I do want to make sure I didn't actually
introduce a regression into the code
though because it's weird that it
happens that I got these two consistent
and then it changes. Yeah, now that
doesn't sit right with me. Okay, let's
make sure I didn't mess anything up.
Just run it
again. I think there is a
is. Advantage is made fresh every time.
Can't be
that values. It is plus values. That's
correct.
check. I'll run this just so I don't
waste time, but then we'll do a
regression check.
Yeah. Okay. I think there's definitely a
regression to check for here. So, here's
what we're going to do.
And if these two diff go do uh different
results, we'll do um a line by line diff
of the two
repos. No big deal.
solid. Let's um let me make sure we
don't have some weird overgression
before
I I run that
Yeah. So there is a regression, right?
This
is this is still
above. As for this little gap, I don't
know.
It's a pure
rename. Okay, this removes but this is
the
trace. So puff advantage
here values rewards done importance
rewards done importance. We renamed
advantages and then
gamma is this. Hang on. Is this this is
the C++ file? We don't care about this
file. This is only the CPU
fallback. So there's
vrace. Then what we're looking for here
is
importance
vss.
Okay. BS plus offset gets deleted.
That's
it. Then shared
here. Okay. So, we just have to
compare this version to that version
directly. It's because that's the only
thing could have
changed.
Could technically be some dumb seating
stuff, but you just got to make
sure. This is
buffer. Okay. And then this is the new
version.
VS gets
set. Shouldn't care about
that. We don't use VS anywhere,
right? Yeah. This is the output. We
don't use this.
So the code's identical, but we're
seeing a
wonky. I want to make sure that if there
is a regression, we don't miss it.
But I can't see what it would possibly
be.
There shouldn't even be a change to
clean puffel,
right? Like, let me see.
Yeah, there should be no meaningful
changes to clean puffer here.
right? That's like too sketchy, right?
For there to be a several
point PF difference between these two
branches. Let me keep looking a little
bit.
The thing is we don't use this VS at
all. Like this doesn't get
used. Let me make sure it doesn't get
this but this doesn't do anything
because we don't use VS for anything.
regression. There's no way that every
single run I I do on one is better than
every single run that I do on the other
without no regression. That would be
insanely unlucky.
It's the meantime. It has to be
something in here, right? It has to be.
This is the whole
diff. Hang on. The shared
file max
horizon. These don't
something? No, it was called gamma in
the old version as well.
Oh, hang on. Isn't this But that's
Vray's dummy.
Neither of these use BS. And this is
going to be this is going to replicate
still,
right? Yeah, this is still like super
low.
Um
yes check is correct.
This is definitely one of the weirder
regressions I've seen.
again. But if I don't know what's
wrong, it's probably not going to go
super
well. I'm going to read this one more
time very
carefully and then I think we're just
going to have to revert to the good
version.
You reading this,
dude? Well, I'm I'm reading my own
code. I'm trying to figure out where the
regression
is. It seems like it's identical to me.
right? There was
um Okay, so
this removed version
here, this is missing
lambda, right?
But this is the CPP. That's the So this
wasn't getting
run. So we do not need to care about
this. We need to care about this.
Yep, that's a crazy
regression. This code is in every way
that I can possibly see.
um Can we just take like the
old block of code from here and see if
this does anything?
one. It should be as simple as just
remove
this, remove
this,
Yeah, it's it's super weird to have like
a
um just like a
small regression like that. That's very
odd to
have. Usually either break the thing or
you don't.
Curious how entropy propagation under
constrained people shifts in lat action
space.
No, that's
Cicero. What is
this? Yeah, I don't know. I don't know
what you're referring to
there. Okay, so this doesn't seem to fix
the regression. No surprise there.
I don't know what they they have to do
with
propagation. Yeah, I know what all those
words mean individually. I don't know
what they mean together, man.
bizarre. I could just go grab the buffer
version and get it started on neural MMO
already.
Good
work. Yeah, I'm sorry. I just I don't
know what I don't know what
you're entropy propagation under
constrained PP. Yeah, I'm not
sure that. And then I don't know enough
about the cicada problems to know where
any of this stuff would be
like there were like some hard crypto or
not crypto steganograph steganography
problems released at one point. That's
about all I know about
those. Okay, something is definitely
screwy here because all I did was paste
this in. This should be truly identical
code, right?
Values, rewards, duns, importance,
advantages, gamma, lambda,
rewards. Yeah, this code's identical.
So, I just pasted an identical function.
It seems so stupid to go back to the
original
code over what like has to
be I'm running that again now I'm
running that again. We're figuring this
out. It is technically entirely possible
that we just have gotten like really
really unlucky and we got like five runs
on one branch that do better than five
runs on
another. Very unlikely, but it's
possible. Let's see if this ridiculous
thing repro.
may as well start a run in the meanwhile
on
Yep, this
runs. Trains nice and
Yeah, I think we just go back to buffer
and then the next time we refactor it,
we do it
incrementally. That's like ridiculously
low of a result.
Okay, we just we leave uh we just chill
with
now. So, first thing I wanted to see was
uh can we do anything at all off policy
now? So, if I just do
like
replay actor
Can I do like an 025 replay factor and
have it do something?
saw message fe seems to work.
Nope, it
doesn't. Um, we came up with a new
algorithm. It's now puffer advantage.
Puffer advantage is now superior.
So, replay still doesn't
work, but I'm not convinced. Um, that's
not for other stupid
reasons. Let's go to zero
factor. How does it differ from VAE and
V trace? It's both of them
together. It's literally a
generalization of both to have to
include both VR trace and J.
This replay factor thing controls
um it allows you to keep some experience
around so you can use it off policy in
later epochs. This is something I've
been trying to get to
work. Okay. Okay. So, it doesn't seem
like we're screwing up on
um multiprocessing anymore,
right? Does Puff Advantage have
different hypers?
Nope. Same as J
Yeah, I it still doesn't seem like it
helps with this replay. So, we can start
investigating whether
um whether that's a separate issue.
Algo improvements are really exciting.
Have you tried it on MMO yet? Yeah, we
just launched that
run. That's actually kind of encouraging
if you look at it, right? Like
I guess it's hard to say. A lot of them
get a few little spikes at the start.
We'll have to wait and
see. They are a little
higher. It's not really going to be
informative until it runs for a
works not quite as good as the other
ones with multipprocess but similar.
It's no longer like
crashed. Nitrox impulse war sweep with
puffer advantage.
Yeah, you can probably just run your
current best hyper pram with it
honestly.
I'm really curious about your
qualifications. Uh, did an undergrad in
CS Stanford, did NLP, vision, and a bit
of RL there. Did my PhD in reinforcement
learning, multi- aent stuff. My thesis
is online at MIT. Finished that a year
ago.
And now I hack on all this stuff and
uh made a lot of progress in the last
year. Huge huge amount of progress.
buff advantage does better than J AE
with same hypers. It seems like it does
on par or slightly better.
s which it should because it's literally
just uh it's just J with an additional
clipping term that essentially does the
thing that PO does but it does it
throughout the advantage computation
instead of just on the
loss. Okay, so this still runs. Um, so
there is something screwy I think either
with the usage of all policy data in
general or with just the replay
buffer. So let me see if let's just
assume that off policy is not like this
horrendous thing.
Clipping is one of the main
contributions. It is and I've tested
that though actually the clipping
coefficient at least in the simpler ends
doesn't seem to matter that much. It's
not like 0.1 or 0 2. Even clipping at
0.5 is fine.
So, it seems to me that it's more like
preventing really, really bad updates
than it is trying to keep the model
really close to the old
one. Let me use a restroom real quick.
And then what we'll do is we'll see if
we can figure out this off policy buffer
today. I've got another two two and a
half hours. We should have time. Right
back.
You had a PhD from MIT and look like any
CS
undergrad. Well, I'm
28,
so that's about on pace if you do your
undergrad and then it's a 5-year PhD.
And let me tell you, I look way better
now than I did during my uh my CS
undergrad. In my CS undergrad, it was
just like just pounding tons of monster
and coding all day and not getting any
exercise.
So, I still work a lot now, but at least
I keep in shape.
Let's figure out this off policiness
weird
thing. Let me give this guy hypers.
What do you do for a living?
This I run Puffer
AI. This is a reinforcement learning
lab. All our stuff is free and open
source, but we do sell service packages
to companies. So for companies that are
doing reinforcement learning and uh
having a tough time of it because RL is
hard, we make it fast and
easy.
Okay. I suspect that there's just some
sort of bug here because it doesn't make
sense to me that
um it Yeah, essentially it doesn't make
sense to me that this would not work.
just had to answer some messages on the
side
here. I'm also sort of thinking what we
do on experience
probably just mess with a few
things. I mean, first of all, I don't
know why we're doing this on freaking
puffer grid. It's so
slow. Let's do puffer breakout.
out. This will get up to a decent
baseline.
And
then this experience buffer
rows. Oh, isn't this like completely
jank?
replay. It's kind of strictly more data,
isn't it?
and we just
stall. Is that what
happens? Okay, this is actually like
very very solid of a
baseline. And now, yeah, we
still I mean, we still kind of do
something though, right?
Oh, that's
new. It didn't used to still
solve. Yeah, that's new.
Okay, that still hurts quite a bit
though.
Now, how about importance? Where do we
get this importance ratio?
Are you planning to fix, clean up, or
check anything on
protein? Well, yeah. The code's a mess.
I need to clean it up, obviously.
Possibly make a couple
tweaks. I'm kind of in full steam ahead
mode right now.
Okay, so this is going to mess up all
the training
right now. What if we zero advantages in
ratio?
and we still break everything
apparently.
Buffer. Okay, so I royally broke this
[ __ ]
So, we're going to have to be way more
careful with this apparently.
[ __ ] Okay, there we
go. So now
Let's make sure that this is the same
curve and then we
will next hour and a half two hours we
will attempt to be very very
carefully getting experience uh buffer
to work because I think it's just I
think it's just code
Uh, for comparisons and benchmarking,
Captain, we have CUDA kernels for all
three. I might have to fiddle with the
VREC one a little bit. Yo, what are you
building? Huffer lip, my
friend. Ultra high performance
reinforcement learning.
You can test all these on
puffer.ai and watch reinforcement
learning agents play them in your
on a modification to the one of the core
components of the training algorithm.
This is a new advantage estimation
algorithm. Should be good.
It's going to be very very disciplined
about how we do this.
updated? It does not seem. Oh no, it
does get updated. Experience.io does get
updated.
I'm new to
ML. Only know the basics. What
prerequisite I need to understand your
project?
Well, we have a quick start guide right
here.
So way more accessible than most other
resources in
RL2. Let me put this in the chat for
y'all. It's a few papers, few blog
posts, and uh yeah, most people around
here just kind of like start building
environments and uh you pick up a lot of
the reinforcement learning very quickly
when you actually are building
environments and training on them from
scratch.
Uh, Captain, I'm like running I'm like
making a few very small changes, running
experiment, making a few small changes,
running experiment, and making sure the
curves match.
I literally did that before where I like
I did that I did a refactor
and there was a regression and I like I
spent an hour looking through the code
diff and I couldn't figure out what the
hell was different so I ended up just
reverting the whole thing. It was
with. Nice. Keep up good work. Thank
you. This is a fun place to be.
uh could be doing some dev. I'll say we
have folks that have come in with
literally no programming experience and
have
been contributing valuably within a year
and people who come in with programming
experience and no RL can be contributing
valuably within weeks or less. What was
the refactor for? Just trying to clean
up the implementation a little bit and
somehow I broke something. I literally
went line by line and everything seemed
identical to
paranoid. How is the neural MMO
doing? Oh, that's
interesting. Look at that. You see
that? That's a lot more noise at the
start than we normally have. That's a
good
sign. Obviously, we're not going to be
able to tell anything for several hours,
but
advantages? You don't really need the
advantages for anything, do you?
you end up computing them
anyways. So you don't really need to
store advantages. You just need to store
ratio. Go.
protein always seems to favor runs with
the least amount of steps
possible. Uh so once it dials in all the
hyperparameters that affect
time like the only way it can be faster
is by doing fewer steps.
Generally, it should only adjust that
knob way backwards if
um if it can't figure out how to make
progress
otherwise cuz like I corrected for that
problem several times where it just
pushes to minimum number of
steps. I think I've already corrected
that. At least I was pretty sure I had.
Barl white very well might be
stuck. Well, it will do that if it can't
figure out a way to
improve. But generally what it should do
is it should attempt to sample.
It's going to attempt to sample R. It
like it picks a time and it like it'll
randomly try to sample different length
runs. It should only go really down to
the bottom if that's where it can. It's
it's trying to make progress there. Um I
have to look at it more. I got to come
back to protein. There's so much
algorithmic stuff to do,
man. So much
do? What else do you want to do that you
haven't started on?
Um, fast low RNN's. I got to do that.
Uh, I want to do there's some world
modeling stuff to look into, though
probably not for quite a while on that.
Um, I don't know about phasic policy
gradients. I think it's like a net per
hit across the board, unless there's a
way around
it.
Um, let me answer this.
Yeah, that cabin has most of the stuff.
Holy some cool crazy terrain gem.
All right. What does this
do? So, this matches
uh this matches
the which it should, right?
That seems like it would be fine,
doesn't it?
experience. Thought it was ratio.
Yeah, this is
experience.io
ratio. Let's see what this
does. Does this change anything?
cuz otherwise it's storing arbitrary
data.
Interesting. So match with this.
Okay, that's fine.
I think we actually should just see what
what's in here at this point,
right? Like what is uh what's in here?
Um, why is the experience ratio one at
all the But that's just the last couple,
I guess.
call. This is darn good progress on this
though.
Let me just test this last. Let me just
finish this last
run. Okay, I'm going to hop into call.
We'll see whether he wants to do this on
stream or not. No big deal either
Hello. Oh, god damn it. It's this
freaking RTC connecting
Hello. Hang on.
freaking Razer settings. It's not even
Razer, it's Discord being
shitty.
Um debugging
change server
location and change it
back. Is it like that would make sense
that it's just
uh a weird server thing. Where the hell
is it?
Discord? Does anybody know how to fix
this like stupid looped connecting
thing?
screwed. Oh, there's a new update.
That's probably
why. Damn it.
Is it 89? How do I have 90? Oh, they
rolled it back. That's
screwy. There's no way. would have
uh okay, lovely Linux
problems. Apparently, they rolled back
an install and that screwed
me. Hey,
Aaron, can you hear
me? Okay, let's see why it isn't uh hang
on. Output device. There we
go. That should work, right?
Uh, I don't see anything. Yeah, but you
hear me, right? Yeah. Okay, cool. Um,
that was a fun one. So, Discord rolled
back an update and therefore broke
everything.
Huh. Cuz I had version 90 installed and
it prompted me to like to update to
version
89. So, they must have rolled back a
version.
That is weird. All right, we are on
stream if you don't mind. Um, let me
move um, let me just push these last few
changes. Yeah, I got it pushed up as
well. Let me just move this to share
screen and can you go over start doing
this stuff? Uh, I replaced GA today by
the way. Nice. It's
gone. So, we have finally made a major
algorithm contribution with Puffer.
Congratulations. Thank you.
[Music]
Colonel for that will be uh nicely
indeed very
soon.
[Music]
325. Okay. So that should be good now.
Um I have some old version of meta.
So, I just updated my git orc from them.
Yeah, I'm trying to think to their
master.
Yeah, these things they get so out of
date. I'm trying to think if I should
probably just like sync every hard sync
everything probably,
right? Um, probably.
And this will it'll like internally
clone Metagrid, which is not what we
want, right?
Uh it'll internally clone Puffer Lib.
What about Metagrid?
I have no idea. I did it once. Yeah. And
then I didn't do it since. I think that
we do need to do like it the default's
going
to maybe we just have to point it at our
fork so I just get like tougher AI
metaphor fork or whatever.
Yeah, that works. Let me
see. So I will sync this as
well. And then I think if I just
change I probably just have to change
the setup so that it goes from our fork
uh instead of theirs so we can actually
write to it. Yeah.
And there's all 3.11, right?
Yeah, I think they're all on 3.11. All
their stuff
probably.
Meta AI. Do we need any stuff in Puffer
Lib? I guess we have the LP is in Puffer
Lib, right? Um the LP is in Puffer Lib.
Yeah.
Okay. So, do I point this to your Puffer
Lib fork for now?
H I think I probably do. Right. So, what
we probably do
is puffer
AI/Nrid. Just give me your uh link me
your buffer repo real quick. Yeah.
You want the.get file, the getit link or
the I got HTML. I got
[Music]
it. And what's the branch? There's a
dev. So, uh, branch, uh,
dev_p online learning
progress. Okay. So, I think
it I'm just going to send you the setup
file.
Sure. So that you don't have to deal
with it.
Hey, David. Hey,
David. Just FYI, we're on stream. Yeah,
go. I mean, that's why I clicked in. No,
I mean I mean we're on uh what is it? Uh
YouTube X like all of that. Okay, great.
Yeah. Um I got to run in like two
minutes, but uh is there can I help in
any way to quickly point you at stuff?
Um I mean we are currently just like
getting everything set up with all the
different forks and stuff required. Um
the current plan is that we're just
going to add to the pie this extra LP
thing and then we're just going to have
to figure out how to hook up buffers to
the Syon initially uh until we get
binding stuff. So take a look at go to
Metagrid
uh uh and then pull up uh Metagrid and
uh inside Metagrid. Yeah. So Metagrid
um
Metagrid.py. So this is the thin Python
wrapper. Uh so you can uh see we just
like uh create a me a little bit higher.
Go up a little bit higher like here in
reset end. So in re uh or uh above that
act. Yeah. So there we make it right. Uh
well we call this every time we reset an
an we create a new C environment uh
every time.
I mean I guess we can just pass the
reference and it well and then uh look
search for buffers. Uh so the or
actually yeah search for buff here.
Yeah. So on reset we call we create the
environment and and then we call set
buffers on there. Okay, that's workable.
Yeah, the new stuff that we have is not
quite ready, but it it's I don't think
I've showed you it fully. It's going to
be really really nice because you're not
going to have to deal with Syon anymore.
Um, yeah, we're we're moving all of our
stuff out of Syon, so they'll we're just
going to have like a a thin binding
layer and we can uh do whatever. How
does uh how's this look like for a
binding layer? Uh whatever whatever the
binding air layer ends up being, we
don't care. Okay, cool. I just if you're
if you do you can do your own custom
pipe stuff if you want as well. I came
up with a really nice way just with the
Python C API that makes stuff really
easy to debug and has very low overhead.
But if you want to do custom, that's
fine, too. Whatever. We'll figure that
out. Um, and then if you go back to
Metagrid, um, and, uh, go to Meta. So,
uh, go to the folder Metagrid uh, and
then pull up Metagrid.pyc.
So, this uh, yeah, so this is the py.
Sorry. Uh, yeah. And if you scroll down
um, yeah, so we have things to this. So
uh scroll up a little bit higher. So
here uh basically this is a subclass of
grid env. And mostly the stuff you want
to add is to grid env. Uh uh so uh
uh that's basically this is just a thin
wrapper around grid
env. Uh so those are the three files you
care about is metagrid.p PY Metagrid NP
py Metagrid pyx and then grid n pyx.
Okay. Yeah. Um I think then we should be
good and we will see if we run into uh
any big issues. Initially we're just
going to randomize or LP over maps.
Ideally there's actually like some
diversity in the maps based on the BCG.
Maps slash uh
hyperparameters are also valid. Uh what
do you mean by hyperparameters? like
environment parameters, right? Yeah.
Yeah. Like your environment parameters.
So go so go look at uh uh Metagrid uh
and pie the previous one.
Uh where was this thing here?
Um so uh here where it's uh get new
config. Yeah. So if you look at our end
configs um uh we have a resolver in
there. So you can see in get new end
config it like takes the end config it
copies it and then it calls resolve. So
like go to the metag the top level thing
uh of metagrid and then go to configs uh
oh or config. Yeah top yep go to configs
uh and then look at like simple
so you can see the dollar uniform
stuff. Uh and then at the very top uh so
at the very root of the config is a
parameter called sampling and that goes
from zero to one um it's in metagrid uh
so this inherits from metagrid uh yeah
so here you can see there's sampling
it's by default zero so anytime you have
this dollar uniform thing it means uh
sample between zero and 100 with the
center at 50 and uh scale it based on
the sampling rate. So at zero, it's
always going to pick 50. At one, it's
going to pick anywhere between zero and
100. So this is uh already built in
domain randomization. Um, I don't know
if this is useful for you, but this is a
really easy way too. Um, yeah. So, like
the way that I was thinking about this
was for the LP,
uh, sort of just taking all of your
hyperparameters that you're setting
here, making all those into a key, and
then doing your doing the LP over those
keys. Yeah, that that seems good. Yeah.
Uh uh feel free to uh change this and
add uh or you can add or you can use the
resolver add your own resolver if you
want that generates a dict that gives
you a min max for each one uh and adds
them to anyways whatever whatever you
think but this is how we're doing it now
in case it's helpful. Yeah, thanks. The
one thing I'd really like to get working
at some point is I'd like to get uh like
good training with like all the configs
integrated and stuff in the puffer repo
so that I can like throw all our newest
stuff on it very quickly. Uh that would
be really helpful and like I also I miss
I really miss my dashboard. It's it
makes it really easy for me to debug.
Perfect. You should just be uh all the
stuff is in your repo like um uh
Metagrid should just work in Puffer,
right? who wrote a rapper.
Yes, it is. I technically you're right
that I can do everything through like
the Neptune dashboard. It's It's so much
easier when I have this like this little
local thing. No, no. I'm saying I'm
saying our environment uh like you wrote
a wrapper for our environment. You
should just be able to use it in your I
don't know if I got the full I forget if
I actually got the full like config
loading though or it's just the
defaults.
Uh uh that's fine. Uh just do it with
the defaults. uh that's not going to get
us like good like the domain randomized
version where the LP is actually going
to be meaningful over it, right? Yeah.
But then just like throw a few keys into
the LP manually like do map width and
height and like a few other things.
Okay. Yeah. Ideally like the stuff like
number of this resource, number of that
resource like those are actually going
to matter a lot. So we would ideally
want to have like some reason something
that's like reasonably similar to your
config so that we can directly transfer
results to you as well.
Yep. Okay. I got to run uh glad you guys
are doing this fight. Ready? Yep. See
you
is a number. It's finite. We just w the
config.
Uh config's kind of complicated but also
we are on stream. FYI.
Uh yeah, thanks for the PRs by the way.
I will get to those hopefully tonight or
tomorrow. Uh we had major progress
today. We uh we came up with a general
purpose improvement to J and it's like
solid. Very
good. Excellent. Yep. Okay. How are the
How are the new kids?
Uh great. Congratulations once again.
Have you been sleeping? Uh yeah, more or
less. Uh you know, she's sleeping a lot
less than me. Uh I I tried to watch him
last night and like I don't know, he
started to get a little fussy. I didn't
really know what to do, so I had to go
get her. Pretty sad. Uh usually I'm
pretty good at reading baby, but uh
yeah, baby in the middle of the night.
Hard to tell. Fair enough. Yeah,
but it's dev time now. Yeah.
Okay. So, I was in the process
of Hang on. I was in the process of
doing a
thing. I was trying to get this file for
you. So, that would just work.
Um, this is it, isn't
it?
Metagrid. Yeah, this should work. The
setup file. Yeah. So, we can just do
this.
And I guess this will technically this
will build their stuff so we can test it
with their training and then we can also
just run it through puffer lib native
which is going to be a lot easier for
initial testing I would presume um
because it doesn't run like their
massive stack of everything.
also like when um on like when we
initially pull and get their stuff,
right? That um
should it seems like it could
get
messy. Let me just send you one thing,
Aaron.
Okay. I just sent you one thing on that.
Okay.
Yeah. So, everything else everything
else we're just we're good on. I just
want to let you know that. Thank you.
Let's get this thing
started. Uh, I sent you Did I put that
in voice? I think I did the script. You
just put that in voice. Yeah. Wait, did
I just put Oh, and it just like Yeah, it
expanded all the links, but just put the
Python
in. This is just our setup. Pi file.
This is their DevOps that I built
whatever.
Um,
well, regardless, I Let me go clone
their Yes, you clone You clone. No,
wait. You don't clone their meta. You
clone the puffer fork of meta
and then you run. Okay.
Yeah, I could technically push this, but
then I'm not going to be able to PR the
thing.
Um, I swear they used to have
instructions on how to build it. Should
I fork off of the puffer meta? Uh, I
think you can just because I can give
you perms for that fork. I think you
just clone this. No, not this. My bad.
That was theirs. Yeah. Yeah, that's
theirs.
I It's okay. I've been I've been deving
a while. All right. Give me a second. No
worries. Okay. So, this is Yeah. Our
fork of this
And then I think that they have set up
stuff. I I don't use cond for it,
but welcome YouTube folks. Welcome
Twitch
folks. We are currently
integrating a curriculum learning method
into
They have pictures here. Yeah. This cool
environment.
Okay. So, this is their setup.build.
Is this party open invite? Yeah, you can
just join the You can just join the
Discord, Ryan.
Yeah, this is setup. This is their setup
build. It doesn't need numpy 1.26,
right? I think that's like legacy
crap. Probably. I'm not sure.
Yeah.
Hey, Ryan.
Hey.
J has fallen.
I'm excited, Joseph. I am very excited
by that. I've been trying to get like
the lasting algorithmic contribution for
Puffer for a long time, and I think this
is definitely
it. This is going to be solid.
I'm sure Ryan wants to see some more
some more numbers. What is wrong with
this garbage? Like, where is it?
Uh, look
at Oh, yeah. The best part of starting a
new project, installing dependencies.
Best part of Python.
This is the only thing that makes me
There's like too much stuff pinned. It's
a lot of work. Well, Python is just
[ __ ] is what it is.
Like, do you need all this stuff?
Really?
Like, do you really need all this stuff?
You sure?
Is it like trying to install this with
the wrong Python or something?
That's usually what's happening. If they
have all that pinned, it must have
worked together. I was pretty sure I got
that though. I thought
it's like three 3.9 like what? Okay,
there you go. A real a real
error. Ah, here it is. Yep. Yep. Yep.
Yep.
It's Python
3.11 mp.
Oh yeah,
we'll work for you if you don't have a
bunch of degenerate Python versions like
I do.
I don't know how you do research without
a bunch of degenerate Python versions.
Yeah, exactly.
Look, I've been I've been writing CUDA
kernels today. All right. I've been like
fixing CUDA [ __ ] today, which turns
out it's actually when you get over
initial setup is not bad cuz it's just
C.
But I don't know. It sounds fun to say
I've been dealing with CUDA all day. I
mean, if that's if that is true, then
why is it so hard for AMD to write good
CUDA things? Well, because they're just
bad.
What? Uh, so I I just ran that DevOps
install and it ran fine
on box five.
Did I miss one of these somehow?
Uh, I don't know. Yeah, I did. Look, you
see all this?
What uh what Python version do you have?
Uh, by default, we're on 312 buffer dev.
314 is actually going to be good when
it's stable. Um, if they fix threading
correctly in Python, I will be able to
simplify our vectorization quite a bit
and get a little bit of perf. That's
actually going to be applicable. Okay.
If they do it
well, if if they sc if they massively
screw it up, I'm probably just going to
get bored of them and write it in C or
something.
And 3 313 is what? 14.
Not not it's experimental in 13.
Yeah.
How's there no puffer?
So now I have two puffer libs on this
box. One of them at the root and one of
them inside the dependencies for meta.
Welcome. Welcome Aaron.
Now, now you're truly a a Puffer Live
user. This seems like a problem.
I assume you want to like install the
version of your home folder so you can
edit it, right? So, probably, but you
like does that break any of their
pathing and weird [ __ ] Look, I use PAM.
Uh, not popular. I use PAM,
Aaron. So the trick for this is that you
just if you're on the same Python
version and you just when you have to
switch back to your project just pip
install- e dot your version and it'll
just like fix your sim links.
Oh yeah, that usually works.
Well, I haven't run into I haven't run
into any issues with it yet, I think. Or
if I have, I fix them in. Well, usually
what happens these days when people have
infra issues, they come crying to me
because I fix all the infra issues now.
Yes. Well, that is what will happen when
you set up your own cluster. Yeah. Yeah.
I kind of we're we're going to order the
machine soon. I have to wait for the
tariffs to make them not seven grand
plus a piece. Um I think that's going to
get fixed though. I don't see a world in
which they'll stick around.
Yeah.
Meta did not match any files known to
heck. Wait. Meta did not match any files
known to get. What? What? What even just
ran? Cloning proper tank. The setup
worked for for Aaron just now, right?
On box five. Everything is all the the
install stuff ran. It all ran. Yeah, I
know. This is
obnoxious. Did you run their script or
my No, I ran your script without the 311
stuff.
The hell is
Um, it says
that the meta doesn't have a
branch. Get checkout
meta. So, do we not have that
branch? Do we even need that branch
anymore? I
Is it
I think that this branch doesn't have
Yeah, this doesn't have all the forks. I
mean, all the Is this new though?
They're on a meta branch. They're not on
their main branch anymore.
I have no
idea about their stuff.
Oh, this is just the their this is a
puff branch. We're fine. Uh yeah, that
code absolutely shouldn't have worked if
you used this because you checked out a
meta branch of your repo which shouldn't
exist.
I mean, is that even get checkout?
Shouldn't it be dashb meta?
No, it's not supposed to be -b. They're
assuming it exists because there I made
them a meta branch in puffer lib, but
now it's just supposed to be the branch
that Aaron is
using. Let me make sure that you
actually did that.
Well, let's run it
again. Uh, nope. That's a different
error.
See, this is why I hate having to like
transfer stuff over. It's just because
like the setup is annoying.
Yes. So, this has now
died when it cuz it didn't know about a
puffer lip folder. Thank you to our
resident advertiser Bet for the folks
watching. Yes, please do go ahead and
start the puffer lip repo. We're almost
at
2K. It's like 14 off from rounding up to
2K, I think. Oh, yeah. Clearly the
installation must not have worked cuz I
didn't see a bunch of building and
siphonizing.
Yeah, I can give you the new file if you
need it. Yep.
This run and then we'll do that.
Um I you know I honestly think we can
probably just like screw with the
Metagrid end code and then run it from
Puffer Lib. We probably only needed to
really set up the Metagrid code, but I
don't trust that the dependencies are
correctly isolated. So probably Metagrid
has some depths that are listed in meta
or something.
Maybe the depths that were in the folder
uh that got created as I had partially
run through the install were only puffer
lib and the fast g deps. Yeah, most
likely.
But you know that's not to say there
isn't aren't others of them. Just the
package level stuff, right? Like it's
very common for things if you have like
a sub package like metag like to
accidentally only put the depths in meta
instead of in meta grid. So I just this
will be easier. Yeah.
code. I want to get back to a point
where the buffer lib train files like a
thousand lines and just solves
everything. That sounds great.
That would be good. I think it's doable.
There's more stuff I want to try
still. All right.
Hey, it worked.
So, I think that this works now. Aaron,
give this to you.
thing, can we just go to puffer li and
run it
now? Oh, that's going to suck. Okay, I
got to go to death.
3.12. I guess technically we could run
it from
your offer
right? Uh, most likely find do a get log
real quick.
Yeah, I did. I saw I saw a birectional
thing there.
Lovely.
Um, oh, is that actually going to be an
issue? Is it like
incompatible? I think this might just be
I have to restart the
container. Let me do that.
Craig, I don't know why it is that
Nvidia drivers just sometimes die in
containers, but they do. If that's if
that's the fix, that'll be amazing.
It usually is.
The setup file you sent still failed
with what?
Command not found for fetching metagid
into puffer tank metadsid.
I copy the right one.
Yeah, the most recent
one from
206 fetch. Fetching puffer lib
into I mean I'll kill it and do it
again. There's something screwy there
because it should I should have gotten
rid of
stupid. The one it's This is the one
that says 311 everywhere.
Hang
on. Okay, so that now does the
thing. Um, let me see what is wrong with
yours. You can just remove the like the
fetch and the pull and stuff.
Yeah, I just killed it. And then I'm
going to try one more time. Got to love
max compile mode lagging the whole
stream. Yeah. Is that a Yeah, you need
an entire freaking 5090 or I guess this
is the 4090. Entire 4090 just to compile
like a few kernels.
I honestly hate this thing because it
never even makes anything faster.
You could just disable it then.
We might just roll our own mu on at some
point. We'll see.
Yeah, I don't have the hardware for
this, so it's the first time I'm seeing
this. This is Yeah, the Muan autocompile
thing. It caches the result, so it's not
that bad, but still annoying.
Aaron, you still stuck.
It's in the
build. It probably
will. So,
I'm
over five. Yeah. I'm just going to wait
until this stupid compile stops lagging.
I'm doing all this in box five. No, just
in a base terminal. Cool thing about a
team is I can hop on and be in the same
Teambox and I can watch watch all the
stuff you do. Well, that's interesting.
I didn't realize that worked. Yeah.
Yeah, it's like shared. Mhm. Okay. Same
failure point there.
So, let me spin up a T-Mo, I guess.
I mean, Joseph could just log into box
five and do it. Yeah, that works, too.
Yep. Yeah. Let me What do I need to fix?
I just change to box five and then we
can do the setup there.
I did mine locally as well.
Let me say
I guess that would have been a lot
easier for me to start pump.
Let me get
the message. There's no T-X.
I can absolutely T-Mox. I have not built
one. What do you mean built one?
I have not launched it in a Team
instance, but I could. Oh, you don't you
don't need to launch it. Just Just get
one in case so it's easier to share
messages.
this. When I was setting up net hack
experiments on our cluster, they they
require like a central server to just
like communicate between different nodes
and the only way I could get it to run
was by opening up a T-Buck session on
the submission node and running it
there. Oh my god.
Nice. So, I'm the bad guy running stuff
on the submission node, but it's all I
can do.
No harm, no fall. I don't think it's too
heavy. I think it just like sends one
message every few minutes. So, I'm okay
with it.
MIT has some of like I'm okay with it.
They don't notice. The whole cluster got
hacked and they didn't realize. So, did
like you think that's bad? Honestly,
like MIT has had like some of the
dumbest like like community college
grade IT fails imaginable with their
clusters. It was like freaking awful.
Imagine too many people are just good at
math. Like I literally I had somebody
yell at me for like getting a Bitcoin
miner on the server when it was
literally that they didn't like they
didn't close any ports the last time
they got hacked because they have all
the ports open.
Just open it up.
I will say I feel like our uh our like
cluster management team or whatever,
they seem pretty professional. So, I'm
actually I'm willing to give them the
benefit of the doubt and say they did
actually get hacked by someone with a
lot of resources.
They got it up a little too fast. This
there was just like a random not
commented
thing. Okay. Usually some researcher
getting bored.
Yeah. Yep.
Well, I think the issue they said was
I'm at University of Maryland, which
apparently does a lot of research like
the government because they're right
there. I think they were saying they
actually Yeah, for now. We'll see what
happens now.
But they they thought that some nation
state attacker was like hacking their
cluster to get experiment data because
of that. China, Russia, Iran, and North.
Yeah, who knows? Because because they
need to know does curriculum learning
work, right? They're all they're going
to be very disappointed in those
experiments.
Also, I got a picture of the UMD gym and
I was just like incredibly jealous. It's
just like what why the hell do you guys
have the nicest stuff of like any
university? Like what the hell? It is
nice.
I've only everyone's always there. I've
only been to the UBC gym once and the
line was out the [ __ ] door. So, I
turned around and went home. The line
for the gym. E that that's the problem.
They have really nice gyms, but they
also have like like 20,000 students who
want to use it. Yeah, it's just Yeah.
Actually, now I'm curious to look it up
again. What is the population of UBC?
Yeah. The new puffer facility includes
ample floor space for my own gym.
Woohoo. See, that's way better.
Uh, a total of 71,000 students at UBC.
Jeez. Jesus.
60,000 at the Vancouver campus. I didn't
realize it was that 40,000 at UMD.
That's twice as big.
The weird thing is is like it clearly,
right? It's a giant [ __ ] school, but
it doesn't feel that big. Yeah. Try to
recruit us. You know, you can escape to
Canada for a little while longer.
There's gonna be a terrific coming home.
So,
it's all right. It'll be plenty easy.
Well, you're you're becoming state
number 51 anyways.
Join us.
We're taking all the harp seals. You
don't need healthcare. We're taking all
the harp seals. You're right. Who needs
healthcare when you have guns? Yeah,
exactly.
America flu. If the flu tries to kill
me, I'll just kill it first. Exactly.
That's how we do it.
All right. Uh I think I got it built.
Um
I look at this. This could have taken
what, one, two days. Could have taken a
week for him to put together.
This is a good good advertisement for
Puffer Lib.
We do need just a few more stars on this
thing. What are we at now? Maybe a few
people start it. Let's
see. It's like so close to the 1950.
That'll round up. 1937.
I like I know all these spikes as well.
Like this spike here was from George Hot
uh like starring it and then like this
was from like Tetsuo promoting it to
like his giant
following and then a lot of like the
linear growth was just like consistent
bits of promo here and there. We need
some more influencers to uh to rep
puffer.
It's too bad. Too bad cash is I mean I
don't know. I think we're going to do
the like industry use side of Puffer is
going to start getting very large as
soon as I like ship some stuff and start
actually doing that side of stuff. Um I
would agree. The next release though is
gonna make it so much easier because
like, okay, all our stuff is really
fast, but now we also have better
algorithms and like just better
everything.
Yeah.
Yeah, I agree.
I wonder what Marco's using for his
research. You know, he's working for a
German uh
egg company.
Uh getting the weed zapper to zap weeds
and other other similar things.
Oh yeah. Is that RL? Yeah. He's doing
straight RL. He's got the whole AI he's
their whole AI team. Yeah. He showed me
a video of a robot arm that that he's
got. It's it can grab like a thing and
put it in a tote. So it's pretty good.
It's gonna like pick cabbages and stuff.
I think
cabin robot arm. Yeah. Are we supposed
to be saying all this debug stuff? Yeah.
No, this is not debug stuff. This is um
So, this is Muan doing a max compile.
It'll catch all of this though. So,
there you go. So, now this is 400,000
step per second train. I don't know if
we're getting any infos out through the
logs or not or if it just takes a while
or whatnot. I think it does. But um
yeah, now we can like do stuff. Okay,
there you go. Now it's like Where's our
LP? Great. So, this should be perfect
for this.
Um there's the plugins. Just two.
Just two. the
plugins just so I get my editor on this
box.
I'm going to pull all this and just do a
local setup, too.
There we go. All right. Now, I got my
editor. We're good to go.
So, this is where LP goes.
Let me look at your thing.
Probably goes here, honestly, because
they set the buffers when they reset it.
Or like here. Yeah. Yeah, it'll go. So
it'll fit somewhere in there. Yeah,
something like
this. And like add just a set buffer.
We'll just add this extra buffer, which
is you only need one, right? Like
levels, maybe levels and difficulty or
whatever.
Um I just need a way to know what any
given environment is working on, right?
I need to know what task they've just
finished basically. Yeah. So we just
expose all that through Syon for now.
Yep. So I'll I got to send that stuff. I
got to send it to the thing so I can
make sure I get my dinner stuff taken
care of.
So, do you know anything about this
environment, Aaron?
Uh, I know the GIF that's hanging out on
the center of the readme.
Okay. Feel like I I talked This is
Davey's at Target, right? Yeah. Okay. I
talked to him about it a while ago and I
like saw their initial work on it like
when he he'd only been working on it for
two or three months. So, I have no idea
where it's gone at, but it seems pretty
cool.
Uh, yeah, it seems really complicated.
It seems like I I think he was telling
me that the uh like the main job of it
is that you can assign a different
reward to each agent. That's
like like a unique reward sharing
matrix, I guess, between each agent. So
like some agents will get the exact same
reward as other ones and some will get
like negative rewards based on the
different agents rewards. So you can
like decide who's working together and
who's working against each other based
on that.
Something like that. I we talked about
it a couple months ago and he ran me
through some of the basics, but I don't
recall the
um a lot of the salient multi-agent
details.
Gotcha.
What What did you just look up, Joseph?
How many ounces in a quart? Oh, come on.
Come on. I look that up to see if I
wanted a quart of soup for dinner and it
turns out a quart is quite a lot. Yes.
Really? I have leftover stuff.
Anyways, I'm quite excited. As I was
coming home from an eye doctor
appointment yesterday, I stopped in a
new place. They mainly do like meats for
hot pot, but they had some like frozen
marinated chicken in the in there as
well that looked really tasty. Nice. So,
I'm get I got like a spicy Korean one
and then I got like a honey garlic one
and I'm going to cook those up for
dinner tonight.
Whoa. My favorite seasonings are salt
and pepper.
I can't live off salt and pepper, my
guy. Yeah, that's not I
can I'm pretty plain to Joseph.
Uh, so LP,
uh, yeah, I'll I'll start looking
through their stuff tonight. Okay. Now
that it's all in a working order.
Anything I need to do with this? I don't
think so. Like, at this point, it's just
sort of me integrating their stuff. All
right. There's nothing weird in here
that's going to confuse you and your
side, right? I don't think so. But, you
know, we'll try it and find out. Okay.
Let me know. And uh is Fox 5 stable?
Yeah. Okay, good. Is it six is the one
that's not stable?
Six was the unstable one. [ __ ] hell.
It's like it's one thing after. I think
I'm just going to like what I think I'm
going to do is I'm like if I know which
ones are actually unstable,
um I think instead of sending them to
the new facility directly, I'm going to
ship them back to Main Gear and say,
"Hey, fix all the fans that are rattling
after one year. It's in warranty and
then fix all the CPUs that are still
broken even though I've swapped them
like five times.
Yeah.
At what point do you have to get
like a hardware guy?
Uh I honestly these are only failing
because of uh like black swan Intel
screw up. Like literally I got the gen
of chips that that tanked Intel stock by
25% overnight. No, Intel tanked their
stock by 25% overnight. They've been
working on that for years.
I mean, they tanked it by releasing an
entire generation of faulty chips. So,
yeah, they are they were definitely
faulty. They are definitely faulty and
the fix is making them slower. Yeah.
Well, their selling point. The the new
box I've got here is pretty darn
awesome. It's like really quiet. Really
wasn't much more expensive at all. It's
got uh
9950X in it and a 5090. So, it's pretty
good
and it's stable so far. No problems.
Done several like 100 build runs with
neural MMO.
How about how about what Pokemon?
Um I think you know I am actually
tempted to just like run new puffer on
Pokemon like in the next version to see
if it does better. Yeah, that'd be cool.
But I also I think that that's going to
be one of the things that we do when we
uh when we do our sample efficiency arc.
One of the things I want Puffer to be
able to do is just like you run
hyperprem sweep with the cost being wall
clock, you get really fast training. You
run hyperparameter sweep with the cost
being samples, you get really sample
efficient training.
Okay, that's assuming that the uh
hyperparameters are the issue there.
Well, no. I mean like on the algorithmic
front, we make it so
that you can use more compute to get
more sample
efficiency there are things I can do for
that. That's in that's intuitive. That's
good.
Yeah. One of the things would be like
I've been thinking about world models.
Um, not I've been think well
specifically for the purpose of right
like a world model is it kind of is like
a soft uh like a soft MCTS thing right
you can use it to do like soft MCTS like
without needing to actually have uh
ability to set states and stuff. So
search scales right we know search
scales with compute. So you can crank up
compute on search and increase sample
efficiency. I think that that would be
like that's probably a pretty pretty
solid way of doing that. And then maybe
like by default, right, you don't
actually do any search. The world model
is just an auxiliary loss or something
that's like, you know, improves like
represent internal representation
stability and doesn't cost you anything
really. Something like that. Whoa. I'm
thinking about stuff like that. We going
to need our own world model. Then
work on stuff. Call puffer world.
I got to find names with all these
things. The protein name for the hyper
pram search is really good. I like
that. I got to figure out other
stuff. Why so many notifications?
Oh, this
reply cuz it's X. It's
always
Yeah. And know and know it's custom
tuning auto.
Yeah, it's almost almost like you've
potentially solved their problem
already. Yeah, was that Oh, we got a few
follows out of that.
Cool. 56.
Nice.
Okay.
Um, it is 5:30. What's the plan?
Anything else I need to help for or
should I go back to doing
uh off policy whatever for a bit? Uh go
have fun with off policy. I'm going to
get myself set up locally as well and
then start looking around. Let me know
if you have any issues. Ryan, do you
have thoughts on Net Hack? Is there
anything I can do with that? I think
it's just like I don't know how Mul ran
a ton of them.
Um you might actually need their
vectorization come to think of it.
Yeah, they definitely do weird [ __ ]
Like there's there is a reason that
there's been three separate RL libraries
designed purely to do an ad hack
experiments. Wait, it's not thread safe
either, right? No, it's not thread safe.
Is it just that the multipprocessing
overhead is lower in C or something?
No, I mean that definitely helps. So the
the moolib library does
multipprocessing. See I think that I
don't know how sample factory does it. I
think actually come to think of it it
literally could be so the way that
puffer does multipprocessing is not good
for like running a thousand processes on
20 cores. It's just not good for that
because we busy weight so that we have
lowest possible latency per core. Um
there's no other really good way to do
it.
Um, so yeah, you might just need to like
get custom
vecib interface and then maybe it's
good. I don't know. But like if that
thing could actually train at a couple
hundred thousand steps per second, maybe
we could get somewhere with it, right?
Yeah. I I think to get to that point
though, you're going to have to change
the model a good amount.
Yeah, but like we have a factoriization
going to help, but we have a 3.1 mil
model that trains 500k with neurmo.
Sure. But the question is if it does
well in that hack because it's got like
multimodal observations and well I
assume that the current baselines are
probably like if they're running on a
hundth of the amount of data that they
should be running on, right?
Maybe I mean like here this is you want
to see a you want to see a learning
curve. I mean this is where is
it? All right this my friend these are
some learning curves. This x-axis is 107
billion steps. Mhm.
And like you can see if we stop at 10
bill, right?
Like or two billion like nothing even
happens by then. Oh, there is the new uh
advantage filtering operation
here. Not bad. Cool. So
far, it's about on par with this so
far. We shall see.
You've run 25,000 experiments on the
oblations branch.
That's the whole project. But yeah.
Damn.
That's that's I've been running lots of
stuff. That's that's the point. Yeah,
that's kind of the point. I mean, this
is
I'm just surprised that Neptune will
host all that without being like, "Hey,
give me your money."
No, they're fine.
They're chilling. They got what? They
got seed funding or something. They
don't care. I mean, look, I'll I'll pay
for a puffer account of whatevers like
as long as they have a free tier so like
users
can make their own plots or whatever and
not like immediately get paywalled with
puffer. I'm fine. Do not do not pay
until they implement dark mode. I've
already opened. Yeah, it's funny. Hey,
bet. Let me let me show you something.
Okay. It's the Chrome extension, I'm
sure. Yeah, I know. You're going to show
me the extension, right?
I'm just going to show you Neptune
hanging out in dark mode. Uh
playing playing hard to get. Uh you know
how long I spent looking for the the
[ __ ] option?
Uh yeah. Yeah. Very nice. Yeah, very
nice. Was like teasing
like sci-fi mode and whatever and it
looked really good, but it's slow. I
actually I got um I I had a DM from the
CTO a while ago just like asking for
feedback. So I gave him some feedback on
stuff and like I don't know. I think
they're just suffering from like growing
too many engineers as a tech company
that's making like a relatively simple
thing that doesn't need that many
engineers and just needs to be done
really well.
They need a they need a front-end guy.
Actually, it just needs more engineers.
I like I don't know. I would literally
just be writing the freaking UI in Rayb
just have like just run the freaking
code and see and call it a day and then
it would be fast. Yeah, it actually
can't be that hard, right?
Yeah, I don't think so. You you'd have
to pipe stuff around a SQL, I think, but
that's about
it. Right. So the question of today is
why does off
policy not work?
Also up to an exploration problem.
It's always an exploration problem.
Oh yeah, we also have an algorithm I
think we're going to use to replace
entropy bonus. So that's kind of cool.
It's coming. The news is coming too
fast, Joseph. Too much. Yeah, I don't
know. I just I need to work more hours
and then like get all this stuff done.
They're non plused. That's what it is. A
serious non plusing.
Yeah, I realized for those uh net hack
experiments, my cluster is on its one
day of maintenance a month, so we'll
have to wait. Dang. Damn.
Unlucky.
Is it even a clust? Oh, this wrong
branch.
I did run this fun experiment though
where uh I realized that the like
learning progress curriculum helps for
net hack for like 200 million steps. It
learns a lot faster and then it like
levels up off to be a lot worse. So, I
just started using domain randomization
from some checkpoint at 200 million.
It's actually doing pretty well so far.
Neat. This is the first thing I've seen
that is above domain randomization. So
that's cool. Yeah, you have to run the
experiments really low. Like I thought
that this one was going to be worse
because it intersected over here. This
thing uh and then it like Well, to be
fair, this one didn't get run all the
way either, but like it like curved up
at 60 billion steps.
Yeah.
So, these are pretty clean curves
overall. Like there's a little bit of
weird concavity, but overall they're
pretty good. Mhm.
I mean for stable build, do you make a
new algorithm which just has
like bandit style sampling for which
curriculum learning to use at any given
point in time and do it and do a meta
curriculum over the curriculum learners
that I already I kind of have half of
that implemented already. And I'm not
gonna lie, I was thinking of some crazy
[ __ ] today where you have like Yeah. You
basically you basically choose at any
point which curriculum to sample from.
Yeah. Like anytime you're going to
sample a task, you instead sample a
curriculum first and then do that. Yeah,
you could. I think it's actually
so looking at this curve just you know
starting a checkpoint from like a little
bit of learning progress and using
domain randomization after that. I think
the next step is you you anneal between
two curriculums where you know you level
off between learning progress and
eventually swip swap to pure domain
randomization.
Experience replay kind of has like a
nealed prioritization.
Yeah, that makes sense. So it
prioritizes a lot at the start and then
not as much later on. Yeah, we have that
implemented as well. Okay, cool. I
didn't realize that. Oh yeah, that's
kind of similar. I just implemented it,
but yeah, but yeah, you could
theoretically have a curriculum over
your curriculum like, yeah, one teacher
is really good at the start of training,
so use that. One teacher's really good
in this particular scenario. Um, sounds
insanely hard to train, but
cool. I think the problem is there's so
much easier stuff, like so much other
lowhanging fruit to test before you get
to that insanity. Like we don't even
know like a kneeling no one's ever no
one no one's ever written a paper on
like a kneeling between two curriculum
that aren't just domain organization I
assume honestly no one's written a
curriculum like that uses like sampling
seeds and reward functions with the same
curriculum like people just don't
there's so much low hanging for you to
explore yeah a lot of like the best
improvements so far in pop have been
really simple it's just people yeah just
did it
wrong it's almost like you could write a
whole PhD D about curriculums.
Yeah. You know what the sad thing is? I
wrote a whole PhD about the
infrastructure to make it possible to do
that research and then did none of it.
Well, I kind of did similar with neural
MMO, right? It's like, wouldn't it be
cool if we had an environment that we
could Oh, wait. We can't really train on
it. It's too stupid. And then I just did
it like in a few months after my PhD and
now it's great. That's what I'm planning
to do now. I'm going to go sit down and
run all of the net hack experiments that
I've been thinking of while I was
writing my stupid thesis and I didn't
have time to code. Oh my god. I've I've
done nothing but write down ideas for
three months because I didn't have time
to code any of them up.
Yeah, that's annoying.
That's that's PhD stuff. Yep. The ending
is brutal because the rest of it's fun.
You're just like I love writing
experiments. I don't know why you spend
so much time. Like I think I spent a
total of maybe 4 days writing my thesis.
I am 100% sure that if I only spent four
days writing a con a paper that
constitutes a fourth of my thesis, Jeff
would have me shot.
No, I spent four days writing my whole
thesis. Yeah. Is that per day? Yeah. No,
I spent longer on Well, actually, I
didn't spend longer on some of the
papers. I think one of the papers was
like a three day. Yeah. Okay. Whatever.
The early papers took a long time and
then they got rejected constantly and
then the later papers that got accepted
were written in like 3 days a piece or
less. Academia is dumb. like I needed to
write more to support the fact that the
research in the thesis was not that
exciting and I had to like I had to
spend a lot of time writing up the
scaffolding for why I wasted all my time
working on some of these projects and
why they were important cuz there is
like an overall motivation in the thesis
but it's not obvious from the projects
cuz they're all kind of random so I feel
like I don't know I didn't want to just
put out a piece of [ __ ] like I don't
know I worked on this for 5 years I put
a lot of work into it I It's not like I
wrote a ton. You just like you wrote you
write like a few paragraphs, an intro, a
conclusion, and then like the glue in
between is all your papers. You just
copy paste all your papers. I think mine
needed a lot more glue than yours to
make sense. Oh well. Yeah. I kind of the
same thing for I didn't write three
papers under MMO, you know. I wrote like
that dreamer paper and then reward
surfaces and syllabus which on surface
level look like completely different and
random topics. They do look very
different. Yeah. The uh the connection
is they are all focused on I guess
getting specifically PO or like simple
methods to work on hard games. But yeah,
I don't know. If you want to know the if
you want to know the motivation, you can
read the thesis. I spent three months
read writing that [ __ ] Jeez, it's
mostly glue. I did spend a few solid
events, but uh you see Ryan, I'm more of
an auditory learner. I learn better when
I hear things. We want you. I'll I'll
get the audiobook going right away.
Thank you so much. You just put your
defense up on YouTube, right?
I should do that. Actually, I need to
find the recording. I mean, they were
like they were like I don't know why the
hell they asked you a bunch of questions
during your defense. It's kind of
obnoxious.
Yeah, that was interesting. They also
could have gotten better questions if
they were going to do that. Yeah, they
asked me very specific stuff. I some of
them, right?
Yeah, that was I don't know what the
hell broke here. Um, what's the point?
I definitely got grilled at the end,
though.
Peter Stone asked me some some real
hard-hitting questions about like my
definition of curriculum learning and
what does open-endedness actually mean.
You know, I don't think the field has
agreed on that definition. Yeah, he
wasn't happy with that answer, but that
was the best I could do. It's like no
one really has a good answer. I talked
to some people a day before the defense
on Twitter like trying to figure out
what a minimally open-ended environment
looks like and they had no idea and they
wrote a whole 20page paper defining
open-endedness.
Yeah. Well, I mean like right Jeff's
answer is just an environment well a
setting where your goals can always be
changing, right? That's like the
minimal.
Yeah, but that's not formal. That's like
literally your goal is always changing.
I can just like here the puffer fish
goes and collects food. I keep putting
the food in different spots.
Well, yeah. That's the problem. Like any
environment that
from the perspective of an agent,
literally every environment is
open-ended for at least a little bit.
Like cartpole is open-ended until you
get the physics down because there's new
challenges until you figure out, ah, I
can generalize over starting positions
and then I've solved the game. So
there's there's like there's this idea
that open-endedness is actually like a
temporary property of environment and
it's dependent on an observer. Like
Yeah. Like that's that's Lisa's and
Tim's arguments basically. Yeah. Which
kind of makes sense to me cuz I don't
know how else you would define it. Like
I don't know how you would define that
some environment obviously has this
property of infinite complexity cuz I
don't know if you could I feel like even
the real world like there might be some
limit you know like eventually you learn
enough that there's nothing to
generalize over. Maybe that's wrong. I
mean I don't think the real world has
shown that to be true.
I mean it's definitely like bigger than
it would ever be feasible for anything
we create to do that. But that doesn't
mean it's not possible for like I don't
know fair an infinitelysized learner or
something. I don't know.
But like even just like from the
perspective of us as people, right? We
are still learning new things. Yeah, I I
agree with that. From our perspective,
real world is definitively open-ended,
but it requires it to be from our
perspective because I don't know if like
the real world from any perspective
actually has infinite complexity.
Yeah, that gets kind of philosophical.
No, I make the argument in the thesis
that we can just assume that the
environments I'm studying are open-ended
from the perspective of an agent because
there's way too many challenges for it
to learn in the amount of time we're
training it. Joseph, you did this
already. PR you haven't addressed yet,
man. It's like I screwed up because I
like I swapped over. It's in it's in one
of the two PRs, but it's I'm sure what
what I got. I got take a phone call. Uh
Ryan, let's chat later. Yes, for sure. I
was going to try to just quick fix this
so I can just run. But yeah, I kind of
screwed up by uh by rebuilding and like
swapping stuff in this state.
Big mistake. That's dev branch, right?
No, it's buffer, which is like not
[ __ ] stable at all. I haven't I
haven't touched buffer, but you just
need to rename the C the functions C CEP
and C reset and C render. Yeah, I I
think I'm going to do that for now just
so I can get this thing done and then
I'm going to merge and then I will we'll
PR. Yeah. No, just just rename those
functions. That should be good because
in the dev it's just reset and step,
isn't it? Yeah, reset step and and
render just for consistency. The only
one that matters is step, by the way.
But but they have to be consistent with
the
mbinding h file. So that's how they are
in
mbinding should work.
Uh, C C render.
What the hell? It's something is
supposed to be. Just rename rename the
rename it to C render in the
M. Rename. Well, it's cuz it's it's
it's in the binding file. It's wrong. H.
Just rename everything to C everything.
C render, C step, C reset, and then just
leave it. Yeah, I think we're gonna
we're gonna spend tomorrow, I think,
cleaning up a bunch of this [ __ ] because
like it it works for you sometimes, but
it does not
work for me nor for other people with
the just name step because of that. Why?
I don't understand how the
[ __ ] I think that way I accidentally did
this [ __ ] No, this is going to break
everything. Hang on. It
won't it it's it's it's it's you only
you only have I think that I need this
is going to also conflict with your PR
if I do it here. I think I should just
take your PR. No, no. On dev in the M
binding file, everything is already
renamed C.
C reset, CEP, and C render. That's how
they're named in the M binding on dev on
dev branch. So I've made them all
consistent with all the Ms that have
been converted. So everything will be
consistent in dev branch with the C
underscore
uh notation.
C
reset. Name them all. C reset. Name them
all. C step. Name them all. C. There
should be two. Yeah.
I'm getting just kind of tired and
hungry here.
It's dinner time. You ordered your food,
I assume. Mhm.
I'm sorry, Joseph. We can't let you take
a break until you solve a little more of
RL. Get back to work, buddy. We need one
more I'll go before. Yeah, we're going
to need one more break there before
bedtime. Man, Sunday sucked. Like, I was
planning on going to brunch at like 1 or
whatever and or like noon and this the
IT guy showed up like 2 hours 10 minutes
late and then was here for like 2 hours.
So I ended up like I had literally I got
up I went for a six mile run and then I
just didn't get to eat a total 24 hours
and then like I had like a three pound
dinner.
O that's
horrible to run.
Run is good. Are you still in the Bay
Area or I'm in What the [ __ ] is this?
I'm in Florida right now and I will
actually be going to Maryland in a
couple of weeks uh to I'm not in
Maryland. Yes. Well, we missed each
other then, but I will be going to the
new facility and uh I will be getting
initial stuff set up there and there
will be some cluster outage time, I'm
sure, because I'm going to have to ship
machines. Um Okay. But yeah, then it's
it'll be good. We'll get them in the new
facility. Stuff will be way more stable.
Everything's on a UPS and then I just
like start adding equipment to there and
I start like adding all sorts of stuff.
It'll be good.
All right. Well, let me know when you're
heading down. I mean, I'm not sure. I
got a few things going on in May, but uh
I got some friends in the area, so and
it's only like a three and a half hour
drive, so I could come down. That's a
fun setup. It is absolutely a fun setup.
When I when I visit, I'm going to be
crashing crashing on site, right?
Uh I would have to get like Yeah, I
could get like an air mattress or
something. Sure. I can sleep on floor
along with To be fair, the floor is
going to be uh it is rubberized flooring
because it's like 3/4 inch rubber mat
for the gym floor. That sounds
comfortable. That's comfy. Does very
comfy.
Yeah.
All right. I also got to hop, but uh
it's fun chatting. Congrats on the new
developments. I This algorithm is going
to be pretty freaking cool, I think.
Yeah. And I'll uh I'll spin up those Z
hack experiments in like a day and a
half when I get the cluster back up.
Solid. I think it's also like I got to
get the off policy stuff working because
that's where we're really expecting it
to do better. Sure. It it'll be
interesting to see if it works with net
hack because that is actually more off
policy since it's
um more asynchronous than I assume what
you're working with. Well, I have to get
the I have to see what the heck is wrong
with the way we're doing it at the
moment. Mhm. That might give some
insight.
All right. Well, I'll let you know when
I get that up and running. See you guys.
What is this tensor tensor? Hang on. Let
me find it here.
So this
Oh, because replay factor isn't set.
Yeah.
Uh you should uh you should get
a a document going with your puffer liib
um breakthroughs or the there will be a
blog post. There will be probably a very
long blog post.
Um, they usually do pretty well as, you
know, they also they usually do pretty
well, but it's like I can write or I can
build. Yeah, I know. I know. I know.
It's it's limited. I was thinking more
just for you to to keep track of and
also to, you know, to to point to so
that you don't have to explain every
single time to every single person. I
mean, it's kind of a lot to explain,
right?
Yeah. You just run it and it solves your
stuff.
That's the you you know no PhD
researchers are going to be satisfied
with that answer though. They will when
it solves their stuff and they no longer
when it actually works then they will be
it does actually work to be fair. That's
that's that's probably the most critical
part is that it does work.
Okay. So this is like
what is that? There's a tiny tiny
advantage difference.
um
across samples
that's like minuscule. It's doing things
correctly. Yeah. But like this is why in
the prioritized
replay it's kind of just adding some
stale data. Yeah, exactly. So there's
like nothing.
That's normal
SPS. That's Well, hang on. Maybe we're
doing this wrong. This is this is the
ratio, right? We don't
need you don't you prioritize based off
advantages, not
That's something, right? It's going
definitely. Yeah. So, this
here, yeah, there's a decent difference.
Okay. Between these two, it's very
different. Mean advantage. Yeah. The
mean advantage of the best samples is
higher by at least a bit.
3x. Okay. So then that's like
correct and then this ratio
What if we set the sampling to random
here? What if we set sampling
equal to random? Do we recover the
original performance?
Wait, has not this been the original
performance?
You'll see. Two experiments you just ran
seemed to be working normally. So, this
is the uh on policy performance and then
this is the best we've done with some
off policy data.
So, but I don't know if it's off
policyiness or I don't know if it's like
weird sampling bias shenanigans.
or or potentially that the environment
does not benefit from off policy. Uh
also, why do I not
have why does this not show
That's better. Yeah, it is better.
So, it's not off policiness. I don't
think that's screwing us up. At least
not that
much. Yeah. Having an extra 50% off
policy data. Look at that. It doesn't
hurt. It doesn't hurt you one bit.
Yeah. Not in this. It doesn't. It's the
fact that somehow the prioritization of
that experience is
wrong. So pri prioritization's hurting
it.
That's very
weird
right. Yep, that is literally the dinner
bell.
Um, interesting. Okay, I will be back
after dinner for another hour or two.
Uh, so for folks watching, puffer.ai for
all the things. Start the repo to help
me out for free. Join the Discord if you
want to get involved.